e
time being
10:05 I'm going to open the public
5:30 and uh we'll invite up
good morning and um thank you members of
the committee for allowing me to speak
today I'm uh representative Jessica
montain representing straford District
17 or DOA w
5 we have a housing crisis in New
Hampshire the median rent for a
two-bedroom apartment across the state
is almost $1,800 a month and that's not
affordable for most most in order to
afford that level of rent you would have
to have a household income of over
$68,000 a year the median household
income in New Hampshire is now close to
$90,000 so you think well that should be
okay right but a quarter of our
population has a household income of
left less than
$50,000 so that makes it very difficult
for low-income people to afford a place
to rent I believe that both the
Democratic and Republican caucuses want
to
prioritize solutions to the housing
crisis this year and there are over 60
housing
bills um that have been filed this year
but most of them have to do with
changing zoning laws or streamlining the
permitting process there are very few
that are specific to funding affordable
housing projects and this is one of them
it's understandable why most homes and
apartments are built for the high end of
the market that's the only way a private
investor can make get a return on their
investment and land Building Materials
and borrowing costs are higher than ever
before the only way we can assure that
affordable housing units are built is
through public and private
Partnerships and the affordable housing
fund is our best tool to help provide
the capital at low interest rates in
order to build the mix of units that we
most need in the
state I know in the city of Dober we
have uh it's seemingly endless number of
new apartment buildings that are going
up it's a very hot area and none of them
are affordable they're all built to the
high end of the
market this past fall I served on a
special committee looking at the impact
of the housing crisis on people with
disabilities having an adult
step-daughter with Down
syndrome and working in residential home
construction myself and being a property
uh rental provider I thought I knew a
little bit about the situation but it
was really eye openening for me to be on
that special committee the
situation uh and housing for people with
disabilities is really dire
um you know for many people with
disabilities they just they don't just
need to find something affordable they
need to find something that's accessible
as well um most new apartments have
elevators but the apartments don't
necessarily have Ada bathrooms or
hallways and the reality is that most
people with disabilities also have low
incomes if a person is lucky enough to
get federal disability
compensation and the average wait time
for that is 78 years the amount one
receives is basically poverty
level so hb30 is a simple bill it
doubles the amount of money from the
real estate transfer tax that goes into
the affordable housing fund increasing
it from 5 million to $10 million it's
not a tax increase it's just requiring
that more of the state budget needs to
be put into this fund to address the
housing crisis
and public and private Partnerships
using the affordable housing
fund
are the way we can help
nonprofits that manage and build
affordable housing properties for
example um an apartment complex that 25%
of the units are fully accessible and
available to people with
disabilities or to build Supportive
Housing communities for people with
intellectual disabilities ities who are
not able to live completely
independently more and more we are going
to need Supportive Housing for people
who are aging and cannot afford to live
in corporate America's version of
Assisted Living I would say half the
seniors in our state are not going to be
able to afford an assisted living
nonprofit but if we do that if we can
build facilities like this this will
help all of us in the housing market
because then you have people in their
empty nest homes that have a place to go
and then free up that house for a new
family looking for a property to
buy the New Hampshire's New Hampshire's
affordable housing fund is long overdue
for an increase my co-sponsors and I are
not the only legislators who think so I
just learned last week that a bipartisan
Senate Bill s
sp81 um virtually was doing the same
thing but their bill is a little more
aggressive than mine it actually calls
for in addition to doubling the amount
um in the annual budget it calls for an
additional one-time appropriation from
the general fund for another $25
million it is my hope that both of these
bills pass and in the budget process we
can come up with a reasonable
appropriation enough to jump start the
projects that we
need so since filing the bill I have
drafted an amendment which I would like
to pass around to
you I probably should have done this
before
so this amendment is partly inspired by
the boldness of the Senate bill to not I
think we took a very cautious approach
like let's just double the the amount
going to the Affordable Care I mean
affordable housing fund um but there
were two things one issue is that after
seeing the fiscal note um seeing that
the increase to the affordable housing
fund would come at the expense not just
of the general fund but of the education
trust
fund so the the wording of the bill was
redrafted so that the increase um it
changes the language so that the funds
going into the affordable housing fund
shall be from revenue remaining after
the deposit of funds to the education
trust
fund the other section of the amendment
makes a prospective appropriation to the
affordable housing fund and that's from
the I kind of got this idea from a
conversation with executive counselor
Joe Kenny about the future sale of the
Laconia State
School um which is going to go for a
little over $10
million and I don't for those you who
don't know that L lonia state school was
for most of the 20th century where
people with intellectual disabilities
were kept isolated from their families
given very little opportunities for
education or
vocation and often kept in deplorable
conditions the school was closed in 1991
as part of a broader movement of
deinstitutionalization and residents
were sent back to their
communities it's generally felt that
there was really not enough planning or
funding
to house this popul population of people
in their
communities and recent well and also
many group homes that were set up at the
time have
failed um that's another whole
problem but the the main problem we see
that we we really don't have housing um
a sustainable housing plan for housing
people with intellectual disab abilities
in their communities in recent decades
children who were born with disabilities
now stay at home with their families and
they go to public school and all that's
great but we're what we're seeing now is
this whole population many of them are
still living with their families and
their parents are
aging and these families are really
starting to panic about what what future
housing Arrangements their children are
and and res there are a lot of
residential programs out there but they
all have long waiting
lists
um so we have across the state a number
of parent-led groups that want to build
Supportive
Housing uh communities for their adult
children with disabilities to live in um
several have already established
nonprofit organizations and are actively
fundraising but they need more
Capital so the reason I wrote this
amendment and thinking about the sale of
this school that did so much harm to the
population of people with intellectual
disabilities is that I see that if we
could take that money which we don't
know when it's going to come in there's
an offer again on the table um but it's
for about $10
million if we could earmark that $10
million perhaps $1 million for each
county in the state that could help
support housing for people with
intellectual disabilities in their
community and that was my inspiration
for the
amendment and it's a way of redressing
some of the harm that was done and also
helping to fix a
problem so that's it okay uh would you
like to take questions yes okay
representative
elme thank you uh do you understand that
taking money
from
the uh real estate transfer tax is
taking money from the general fund and
that taking the money from
the this
appropriation uh from the
the money if that if the lonia school
ever gets
sold um is also taking money in the end
from the general fund and that the
general
fund
uh pays for quite a few of these
services and that the finance committee
should have the final say on
this I do understand that um
I think it's a matter of of making
priorities and I think we have a crisis
in housing and we need to make that a
higher priority I do realize the money
has to come from
somewhere but I think this is the time
that we
housing representative ORS thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
so you said you own rental properties
have you equipped these for handicapped
individuals all your properties and have
you lowered the rents to help get these
people into your
properties um yes and no um my husband
and I have owned several rental
properties um we sold um the last one we
owed owned in order to buy a house to
house um my stepdaughter
um in
it um and and it's what in a
um it's called a home care providership
in which it's um the money for that and
the oversight of that is run by one of
the community agencies Community
Partners in Dober and Eliza and another
um person with Down syndrome live in the
house with two home care providers and
we do rent that at less than market
value
um we were able to build a duplex behind
that property on the same piece of land
um but that we ended up building in
townhouse style because that's the way
it could fit on the lot and that's sort
of what we have to do so the new the two
new units are not accessible and their
market rate but that's the way we can
afford to rent the main house below
market rate follow up follow up thank
you so uh my brother-in-law who turned
81 today it's his birthday his wife
who's about his age though she claims
she's only
39 have adopted a little girl 30
something years ago not real she had
been beaten and not realizing how damage
she was I mean they're in their 80s and
they're still taking care of her so I I
mean it's hard to I I know it's a burden
but I mean the families I mean you
yourself yeah if you're not taking care
of your child somebody else is
so yeah represent what question oh yes
just about to ask you so so what do you
think the answer is like if they can do
it in their 80s what's the answer for
you or people your
age
um well let me put it this way I think
uh my husband Eliza's father um also
coached spe Special Olympics for many
years and when he saw
these older
parents trying to take care of their
adult child with a disability he found
it really heartbreaking and it didn't
look like a good experience for either
the child or the parent at this point
and he thought I I do not want this to
be the future for Eliza nor for me so
when Eliza went was in her late 20s is
when she first went into a residential
home care providership she's still very
much a part of our Lives we see her and
talk to her all the time but she has
learned to have trusting relationships
with another person taking care of her
and that's really going to help her in
the
future but it's exactly that situation
what if your brother-in-law were to die
tomorrow what would happen to his child
that's why we need um places that are
safe and appropriate
for such a person to go live when their
parents are
gone and and we don't have enough of
these which is why we need to make this
investment and we need to do it
now thank you um before I call on
representative opal I just want the
committee to know I have seven more
people that want to speak um just so you
understand that perspective
representative Opel thank you Mr
chairman I'll be quick I I just want to
make sure I understand representative
lontine in in the bill is introduced you
were proposing to take $5 million out of
the real estate transfer tax a third or
a third of that would come from the
education trust fund twoth thirds would
come from the general fund in the
amendment you're proposing if I'm if I'm
reading this correctly you're
proposing uh $10
million uh which up which is an increase
of five yes so you're you're proposing
to increase five
that increase would come strictly from
the general
fund am I funds deposited in the aital
housing fund under this paragraph shall
be from revenue remaining after the so
you're holding the education trust fund
harmless is that correct okay whiches
okay I just just wanted to understand
that thank
you okay thank you saying no more
Saul OPP could you turn your microphone
on
please good morning I'm Ben Saul I am
the council and director of operations
for Visions for Creative Housing
Solutions in the Upper Valley thank you
for the opportunity of speaking in
support of this
bill I I wanted to uh just give you an
example of an organization that has
benefited from these funds and I'll tell
you briefly what we do if you're not
familiar with visions we have three
sites in Enfield hover and Lebanon at
which we support in supported housing 35
individuals with developmental
disabilities many with additional
physical disabilities and complex
medical
conditions two of our sites were
developed with assistance from the
affordable housing
fund and I'll speak briefly about the
importance of support at the capital
phase of projects like ours first of all
the
operating
um income is extremely limited the folks
that we serve they are virtually all on
supported by SSI and they're on Medicaid
so they're not able to pay Market rents
and so you know we're not able to go out
and get a market mortgage because we're
not going to be able to support that
during the operational phase so we have
to look for funds HUD
funds can come encumbered with fair
housing rules which may make it very
difficult for you to use it for a
population where you're limiting who's
going to be able to live in the home
uh we we're complete our our building in
capital phase is complete at this point
but we want to support other
organizations in New Hampshire who are
trying to do this it's very difficult to
do and there's an extraordinary need and
I can tell you from my personal
experience I'm the father of a
20-year-old who suffered a prenatal
stroke and had bilateral loss of uh
lobes of the brain and she is extremely
cognitively impaired mobility impaired
and death blind and so I need to plan
for her future and you know and live
safety safely and as their parents age
and are no longer able to take care of
them I'm glad to take any questions
thank you
questions seeing none thank you for your
DOA good morning Mr chair members of the
committee for the record uh my name is
Tom do roza I serve as deputy director
of housing action New Hampshire uh we're
a Statewide advocacy organization that
supports policies to increase housing
our members include housing developers
both uh nonprofit for-profit landlords
lenders uh property managers service
providers and
others I'll be brief we're here today in
support of HB 530 as the sponsor noted
you know we're facing a housing shortage
uh it's due to limited Supply right
that's led to record high prices and
vacancy rates below 1% they're just not
enough homes for people to live and work
here and that's impacting everybody it's
impacting seniors it's impacting our
young families and the workforce that we
need to grow our economy uh there was a
recent survey done by the uh Bia and the
Center for ethics at St anom College
which found that over 86% of leaders
cited concerns about affordable housing
as their top public policy
issue so we urge you to support uh HB
530 uh the affordable housing fund I
think Jack is possibly testifying but he
could speak more to um the how it's just
it's a great investment we can make
right it's a revolving Loan Fund it's
leveraged more than $500 million in
private Investments since its in its
Inception and it's helped build
thousands of a rental homes uh so again
we ask that you support uh HB 530 thank
you representative
opal just a quick question sir thank you
Mr chairman
um are you also supporting the amendment
as offered we have not had an
opportunity to review the Amendments I
was just speaking to the underlying Bill
okay thank you represent Aly thank you
uh are you willing to advocate for
increased Reven Vues to replace what has
been lost over the years which is
extensive uh given that we are facing a
major Revenue
crisis I mean at this moment I would not
be able to answer that question but I
could certainly take it to our governor
counsel and see where they fall on that
thank
McIntosh hello and thank you for letting
me speak this morning my name is Lori
Macintosh I'm from Dover I'm going to
skip a lot of what I had to say because
um Ben and uh Jessica have already said
a lot of it so I'll spare you that
however I am if I could interrupt you
for a minute there's also uh Maddie Mand
from the same
organization do you guys have different
testimonies
or oh I'm sorry okay right proceed thank
you anyway um so I am uh the chair of an
organization called ourplace NH and we
are trying to build housing for adults
with developmental disabilities because
of the appalling lack of such housing um
and I'm in favor of this bill for this
purpose um just to give you a little
more information there are approximately
27,000 people in New Hampshire with
developmental disabilities
and um in 2021 73% of those lived with a
family caregiver and 27% of those lived
with caregivers over 60 so when you do
the math that's a lot of people we
already have people on our interested
list whose parents are having Strokes or
dying and the this is your next at risk
for homelessness population these people
have been sneakily living in the
community being taken care of by their
parents and you hardly even know that
they're there but there are thousands of
them and they are going to need housing
not only that they want housing they've
been educated they're ready to work in
the community they need appropriate
Services um we have 118 families on our
list farmsteads and Visions the other
two places in the state that have this
kind of housing have lists of over a 100
also so it's dire it's taken our place
New Hampshire 5 years to raise enough
funds to get a loan to buy a former
daycare center which we purchased in
August of 2024 now we need to raise
about $3 million in order to renovate
the daycare center and add four
apartments in order to make it a viable
business so where do we get $3 million
so we're trying to do government grants
that's kind of funny these days um we're
going to try to Sur uh provide
Supportive Housing for 11 individuals
with ID which is a small fraction of the
housing that we need but we're hoping to
come up with a sustainable model that
can be recreated in other
communities
um so New Hampshire is just waking up to
the reality of this housing crisis and
we need to be proactive and provide this
housing in order to prevent these people
from being placed inappropriately in
nursing homes and other more expensive
options if we are proactive and we
provide this housing you're going to
save money in the long
run you can imagine what it costs when a
parent drops their child off at the
emergency room and says I can't take
care of them
anymore um so to save the cost of extra
millions of dollars and also the
heartache of the people who deserve a
better living situation please support
this bill to provide more funding for
affordable housing I'll answer any
questions represent opal
thank you Mr chairman U ma'am same
question um are you aware of the
amendment have you had a chance to look
at it and will you support it about
theonia State School the yes ma'am the
amendment that was offered by
representative lont absolutely okay
thank
you okay seeing no more questions thank
you uh next I have
uh Matt uh Maddie
sorry my name is Maddie Mandel bound I
am a widow and a single parent to my son
Jeremy who is 29 years old when my
husband died six years ago suddenly and
unexpectedly it quickly occurred to me
that my life or any life can end this
way as well well the question was how do
I begin to plan for Jeremy's future now
so that someday he can live safely and
purposefully outside of my home as these
six years have unfolded I have
identified another question how can we
plan for and make this transition in a
step-by-step process rather than in a
crisis environment as so often happens
in our state due to the deplorable
shortage of homes for our intellectually
developmentally disabled loved ones
Jeremy has a motor neuron condition
hereditary paraplegia he uses a
wheelchair to navigate his environment
and has learning challenges that impact
his understanding of how the world
really works but you wouldn't
necessarily know that upon meeting him
he's a handsome young man who is
enjoyable to spend time with and uh has
a very easygoing temperament and great
sense of
humor I just turned 70 years old a day
doesn't go by that I don't question on
some level how much longer I can care
for my son safely when there are
incontinence issues connected to a body
that cannot control itself in a myriad
of ways it is challenging to say the
least and it only gets more challenging
as time goes on shortly after losing my
husband I began networking to learn
about housing for Jeremy's population I
joined the mo centers Family Support
Council to learn about how it may
support Jeremy and me I began putting
feelers out for any other families
interested in the issue of housing as
networking allows I learned of a family
living down the street who was involved
with our place a group of parents in the
do area creating a home for ID adults
the effort was is based on the Visions
model in Enfield New Hampshire I have
been volunteering with our place on
their developmental on their development
committee now for the past 4 years
helping them to raise funds necessary to
move along in this amazing effort
presently we have land and a building
that with the N necessary funds can be
remodeled and turned into a home for 10
to 14 residents but it sits there
waiting for the funds to be raised
before moving ahead into the
construction phase it all takes time the
effort is coming from families like mine
who are caring for the special needs of
our adults
while also learning how and putting into
effect the individual steps of creating
a home absolutely from scratch while the
time on the clock ticks away we watch
our young adults wondering about their
Futures they ask whether they will have
to live with us forever and what will
happen to them when we die Jeremy is
treated for depression and a day doesn't
go by when I don't think to myself that
his depression would improve if he was
living with his peer group making
meaningful relationships learning and
depending upon one another while gaining
a sense of
belonging I have established a housing
committee through the more Center Family
Support council with the intention of
creating much needed housing in the
Manchester area every town needs a home
for its special needs residents to move
into actually it is becoming imperative
that all towns plan to do this soon as
criteria to be accepted into housing is
to be a resident of the town or
surrounding area where the home is being
built funding is the big need not
finding the parents interested and
motivated to get behind such an effort
there are groups of families springing
up all over our state with a desire to
create housing for their loved ones but
it is the funding behind the effort that
is a huge barrier to this happening in a
more timely way funding is needed for
the incorporation process and becoming a
nonpr profit it costs money to set up a
website so that interested people can
follow the mission and important
information can be shared it costs money
to take money to it costs money to make
money such as in hiring a development
person to run Capital campaign and here
I just rais a few of a very few of the
expenses if there is a question about
how available State funds should be
spent just ask the parents who have paid
for some of the above expenses out of
their own
Pockets there are some amazing benefits
to being a part of the ID Community one
of them is meeting other families living
in the same challenge C challenging
circumstances we are we learn from one
another and gain hope for moving forward
in this state of so few resources we
parents are a powerful resource wouldn't
it be impressive if the state of New
Hampshire would join us families in
providing funding toward a need that
somehow has been ignored since lonia
state school was closed it has been
established that our ID population of
loved ones is the population in most
need of housing as they are the most
vulnerable to becoming homeless if it is
not provided for them if funding is
available let us focus on getting it to
badly thank you do we have any questions
blae good morning Mr chair members of
the committee thank you for having me
speak here today um my name is Vanessa
blae I serve as the Director of policy
and planning for the New Hampshire
Council on developmental disabilities
and they membership of the DD Council
asked us to come here today to show our
support in um this bill HB
530 um we believe that this bill would
have a positive impact on the disability
Community um if any of you have any
doubts as to how important the housing
crisis is to the disability Community I
urge you to watch the hours and hours of
testimony that was heard by your special
committee on housing in the last
session there fortunately was the
opportunity to form a committee um out
of HB
1168 that was to study the impact that
the housing crisis was having on the
disability community and we are very
grateful that the sponsor um was able to
serve on that committee and we one of
the aims of that committee was to come
up with policy that we could advance in
order to chip away at the crisis and
ensure that people with disabilities
would have access to affordable safe
stable housing in their
communities and this is one of the many
tools that we could use in order to
attack this crisis
um there are a number of things that we
would like to see done with the funding
that would be allocated to the
affordable housing fund um one of those
things is the assistance in the
development and implementation of
accessory dwelling units also best
practice supported housing communities
such as um some that you've heard about
here this morning and also building um
community-based housing that would U uh
utilize Universal Design
um 12% of people in New Hampshire
currently experience a disability and
every one of us is one paycheck one
accident
one unfortunate event from having
disability impact Our Lives um and it
was said earlier that you know it's it's
time to really take this housing
crisis and attack it the way that an
emergency should be attacked um building
housing for the disabled and aging
Community is an investment it's an
investment in our communities it's an
investment in our futures and we hope
that you take this into consideration
when considering this
Bill thank you represent
Opel thank you Mr chairman and U ma'am
I'll ask you the same question have you
had a chance to see the amendment
representative Al montain introduced and
would you was your organization support
it I I have heard about the amendment I
haven't read it exactly um but in
reference to the lonia state school um
yes we are in support of that thank
you R
Aly thank you I want to ask the same
question that I had would you be willing
to advocate for more revenues because
this is the revenue committee and the
budget committee is the one that makes
these decisions yes we
are thank
you okay saying no more questions thank
you thank
you all right uh next up I
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak today on HB 530 my name is Jack
rudderman and I serve as the legislative
affairs advisor for New Hampshire
housing formerly known as New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority uh I brought
with me um a fact sheet about the
affordable housing fund which our agency
administers uh as well as a letter in
support of HP 530 from our executive
director Rob
dpis for those of you who may not be
familiar with our
organization New Hampshire housing is a
self-supporting public corporation with
a mission to promote finance and support
Housing Solutions for the people of New
Hampshire we do that by running a range
of programs
including financing which has helped
create about 16,000 of affordable
apartments over the past several decades
we offer loans through partner Banks and
lenders to help New Hampshire families
achieve home ownership so we have a uh
firsttime home buyer program that
provides um discounted mortgage rates uh
and down payment assistance and then we
also administer the state's housing
Choice voucher or Section 8 program for
much of the state we do not receive any
opport operating funds from the state
the same state law that created New
Hampshire housing in
1981 was later used to establish the
affordable housing fund with New
Hampshire housing as its Steward and
administrator since then the affordable
housing fund has functioned as a
revolving loan fund and an essential
tool for the creation of affordable
housing Workforce housing and Supportive
Housing across the state
the governor and legislature have made
historic investments in the affordable
housing Fund in the last two banial
budgets we have used these funds to help
create new housing serving a range of
populations and income
levels as this new housing comes online
it is decreasing homelessness and
housing instability improving
neighborhoods uh and helping to improve
health outcomes and um contribute to uh
growth of New Hampshire's Workforce
which we hear from the business
Community is a
um high priority given that there uh has
been now for several years uh a shortage
of available workers um and that of
course um has broader implications for
the state's economy as a whole so uh we
are proud of the work we have done so
far to create new housing through the
affordable housing fund uh we believe
that an increase in funding would be an
important step toward increasing the
supply of housing in New Hampshire
affordable housing at a time when more
housing is desperately
needed uh and for those reasons we
support this bill and we respectfully
ask this committee to vote the bill
ought to
pass with that I'm happy to take any
questions thank you do we have any
your last comment is a bit worrisome to
me agencies don't Advocate they
Implement um what is your question my
question is Sir could
you yes he
is yeah yes they are they're established
by state law uh could you uh Define for
some of the new people and differentiate
between what Workforce housing is and
what affordable housing is sure so
affordable housing uh in a broad sense
uh is housing for which the renters or
homeowners are paying no more than 30%
of their gross income for rent and
utilities or mortgage and and taxes um
Workforce housing targets um households
where the um the the income is uh
roughly 80% of
the average the area median income or a
Mi so um we have buildings that are
geared mainly towards Workforce housing
and and that serves people you know that
work in our community um you know
firefighters um medical
personnel um people who work for our
towns and
cities um sort of average middle-ish
acum folks um but we also have units in
some of those buildings that serve
people who are at 50% of Ami or even
lower than that so some who are
considered um very low
income thank thank
you okay seeing no more questions thank
you thank
and I know your name's longer than that
but I can't read the last and you did
well Jan lard pel thank you for the
opportunity to testify today for the
record I am Jan lard pel and I live in
Candia New Hampshire and I am testifying
in support of house bill 530 and I'm
especially excited about the amendment
of the possibility of using funds from
the sale of the state school
um to support people like my son um who
fortunately never had to live at the
state school but um they could rectify
some of the harm done to people who did
live there I am the parent of a
31-year-old son Micah who has what is
now called level three autism or severe
autism that falls under the diagnosis of
intellectual developmental disability in
Micah's case his diagnosis means he is
non-verbal and needs one to one and care
every waking moment I am blessed that my
6'2 240 lb son is a gentle guy but his
impulsive actions such as bolting away
from his caregivers and Pica which means
eating inedible objects often places him
and sometimes others at risk Michael
lives at home and he has a family
directed program via the Moore Center
Micah's father died of brain cancer when
Micah was aged 14 thus I am his Survivor
parent Micah has wonderful siblings who
will be for be there for him in the long
run but it is my hope that they can fil
fulfill the important sibling role with
Micah settled into a residence where he
can age in place before I am too old to
care for him full-time currently New
Hampshire does not have adequate
Supportive Housing for adults with ID
there are many many families like my own
who are doing their best to care for
their child at home as the housing
options are not available able to meet
their child's specific needs I am part
of a parent group who's connected
through the mo Center because of our
mutual concern about the lack of housing
options for our disabled family members
we are currently in the process of
becoming a nonprofit so that we can
raise funds to create housing for our
adult children passage of HB 530 and its
am its amendment is critically needed to
begin to address the lack of housing for
our adult children the goal to use the
fun fund from the sale of the former
lonia State School to support the
long-term needs for housing for adults
with ID is a win-win for all and it's a
way to positively impact the future for
these vulnerable citizens I'm asking
that you please support our efforts to
provide for our children by voting to
support this Bill thank you again are
there any questions thank you any
questions saying none thank you for
testifying okay that's all the pin cards
I have is there someone who has not
testified who would like to
testify seeing none I'll will close the
530 yes as we through these it seems
like some are much more appropriate work
session I don't know if we want to
um
for
e
okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB
531 and um before I invite
representative Ames up um I think we
didn't anticipate the size of this crowd
um we've got I've got about 20 roughly
20 people who want to speak um I'm sure
a lot of you are going to say similar
things um so what I'm going to do is let
representative Ames introduce the bill
um and after he's done introducing I'm
going to limit every other speaker to
two minutes and I'm going to enforce
that fairly rigorously um so I would ask
you when you you know what's come before
you try to think about focus on maybe
something a little different you know to
make your point but I want to enforce
that uh two minutes thank you
representative
vs good
morning uh I'm here
to introduce and speak to House Bill 531
setting annual limits on the amount of
charitable Gaming revenue which may be
distributed to one charitable
organization and what I uh wish to say
is that uh this uh Bill originated in uh
um out of discussions come comes from
discussions in the uh gaming commission
charal gaming commission that I was a
member of that worked through the summer
under the able direction of uh of
Patrick abami um and
um in the course of those
discussions uh we
um were presented with information
that was of concern I think to most of
the pathway that had been uh followed
with Char the the selection and funding
of
Charities and whether it was a a pathway
that could be sustained it seemed to be
unsustainable um the problem is this the
revenues have
increased uh coming out of charal gaming
significantly
[Music]
um and that has played out to benefit
those Charities that are in the game so
to speak that uh have been able to get
on a list at one of the um facilities
where the revenues are way up and those
are I think exclusively facilities that
have historic horse racing there's also
been some increase in
uh revenues from um uh card playing and
other activities that uh are allowed as
part of charitable gaming that are not
machine gaming and that uh results from
higher bet limits that have been also
enacted so um so more Revenue coming in
for Char gaming that's benefited those
who are on the list uh and have been uh
given days to uh uh in which the
revenues benefit those Charities um and
uh and
not those not on the list Charities
which fire out number of the ones that
are on are on the list across the state
uh do not benefit from this uh this
Revenue stream at all
um and uh it seemed to us as we thought
about this and I remember I think uh
um I don't know whether to call him
representative of bramy or The Honorable
AB brami but uh he's honorable and um uh
he actually uh passed around uh sort of
a thought piece about uh about this that
had a had a limit in it as does this
bill um and part of the reason for
putting a limit in uh during that that
discussion was uh that it would
uh that it would
um buy
time for figuring out a long-term
solution that would work for the
allocation for the uh uh choice of
beneficiaries and uh for the
distribution of this money to Charities
um in the end we didn't include that in
our report although I really don't
remember as I sit here whether there's
any wording in the report uh uh that's
summarizing the issue um so here we are
today I I put this bill in as a followup
to that discussion um and uh and with
the thought that uh there's a real risk
here that Charities who are on the
inside in this uh in this uh system in
other words who are getting higher
revenues um may be
headed may become used to a funding
level that cannot be
sustained once uh once uh in in the
event that a system that's more fair and
uh distributes revenues uh um further or
in a different way uh we'll find it very
hard to readjust to a lower level of
operation maybe maybe the number I chose
was too low uh I leave that here
um your your uh work session and uh
discussions
um and maybe it doesn't is not a good
idea but that's that's its purpose and
in no way in no way does this proposal
suggest that uh any single charity
that's on the list that's currently
getting $100,000 or
$150,000 um should be um uh thought to
be undeserving of uh the funding that's
been provided or that uh consideration
should not be given to the possibility
of of of of causing harm that doesn't
need to be caused so I hope that you
look closely at this bill and uh and
develop a uh position on it that uh
takes into account all of these
realities I think you're going to hear
from some of those realities from the uh
long list that was mentioned of uh that
of people who wish to speak so that's
those are my uh my thoughts on this
Bill thank you representative Ames and
it's good to see you back in ways and
means
of um do we have yes represent
op thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you representative Ames
um as I read this bill I just want to
make sure I'm understanding correctly
are you proposing or does this bill
propose uh essentially a $50,000 cap for
Charities
receiving um money from historic horse
racing and a $50,000 cap for uh
Charities receiving money from other
gaming sources so potentially a $100,000
cap is that am I reading that right I
don't think that's the way it reads I
think it reads as
um the amount collected in any calendar
year um and that's the limit I don't
think you can double up that's my
understanding yeah okay that it it would
appear there are two separate paragraphs
I'm sorry yes follow up it would appear
there are two separate paragraphs oh I
see I see what you're saying well look
at it and uh figure that out we will we
will have a work session on this bill if
I hadn't mentioned it yet representative
you said Thank you Mr chairman and I
thank my
friend would
you would you have reservation with this
bill knowing that 538 the the next
commission gaming commission going
forward this would be something in their
purview to to address because and I want
to add to this the the way this reads to
me is and it's May maybe it's something
for that commission to address but this
kind of looks like we're changing the
whole platform to a grant to these
Charities at
$50,000 that may be the solution to this
at the end but would you would you think
it's a little premature with that
upcoming commission coming with with the
changes in gaming with all the issues
commission I actually I actually don't
think it's premature maybe uh not right
the way it's set out but um the con the
concern is uh I think I remember when we
talked about the charal gaming
commission Bill your use of the word uh
Legacy Charities um and it becomes
uh embedded in the system uh the higher
level and so the thought here was let's
put a pause on it as I said maybe this
number is not right and maybe uh maybe
it's not uh it needs to be uh clarified
as to what it applies to um but
um it does seem to be Merit in in uh in
setting a limit that
uh that will be in play while either the
gaming commission or this Committee in
response to another bill uh works out a
better system followup just quick
followup and and if I'm reading this
correct uh correctly and correct me if
I'm wrong it it seems to me that when
they hit that $50,000 Cap all the other
Revenue goes
to lottery so which changing the
platform we have in totality in Char
charitable gaming which is something we
explored for years and years we have a
platform right now a model that's been
operating this in totality changes that
model and in my
estimation um in the uh immediate uh
aftermath of the imposition of this uh I
I suppose that would be right um that's
true um the
um money something has to be done with
the money it seems a reasonable thing
that go into the education trust fund
which is where it would go and that's uh
Schools okay seeing no more questions
thank you representative am and if you
could fill out a pink card that'd be
great oh um now I have uh 20 pink cards
in front of me and I'll just let you as
I said you know I'm going to limit
people to two minutes uh try not to
repeat because I'll tell you that all 20
pin cards I have at the moment they all
oppose the bill so it's not like uh we
need to hear the same thing 20 times but
of course you know if you filled out a
card I'll let you speak um first up
Chris
Thompson did you have a
[Music]
question I was going to ask uh since
there's a former representative that
served on the commission could that
representative make his presentation
first I'm Sor repres former honorable
representative abami uhuh
yes and of the pin cards I have is there
any are there any current state reps or
current state senators on I didn't see
any but okay seeing none uh yes
representative uh thank you for that
comment and I'm I apologize for the
order here but we will start with
representative
brammy former representative
brahmy thank you Mr chair good seeing
you could be back in ways and means I I
was uh for the for the new members here
I was on Ways and Means for 12 years um
Vice chair where Jordan's sitting for
many years um I was also the chair of
the chable gaming commission which met
for I would say a year and a half and we
came up with a report uh that had 25
recommendations in it and one does touch
on this
topic uh I'm here to oppose the bill
respectfully opposed the bill I have the
highest regard for representative Ames
he was on the
commission representative Janan was on
the commission represent duet was on the
commission as
well um by the way I was the
representative along with representative
duet who brought us uh uh historic
racing machines in this in the
state so I'm going to have to trim it
down to because of the limitation on the
time uh but I I I uh provided you with
two two a a handout I put on the
this during the course of the commission
one Sunday I decided to go through all
800 Charities and try to group them into
what we're talking
about and you could see I think it's
very informational for everybody to
understand that it's a wide breath of
things that these terrible funds go to
all the way from Youth Sports to Easter
Seals to you name
it but I agree that this when I looked
at this I said to myself because we had
five charges in this commission but I
broughten it out to 25 we had 25
questions and one was do we need to
address especially as these casinos grow
charal gaming locations
grow we can have to start addressing how
much what the ceiling should be and how
much any individual charity can make
right now if you go to the second page I
have a slight distribution of of of
that where
34.7% make between 0 and
25,000 uh all the way up to 1.3% make
between 125 to 150,000 for their 10 days
of
sponsorship
so now does a sports team need1 15 ,000
does a little Le team need 150,000 no
Now understand that all these facilities
aren't the same we have big ones we have
small ones the bigger numbers that you
see on that list come from the bigger
facilities like the brook Chasers is
actually even though it doesn't have
historic racing Chasers is one of the
top Revenue
generators so so yes there is no
question that we need to to do something
about this I'm going to read to you
recommendation 17 of the from the report
which um representative Ames is the
report if you watch if everybody Mr
chair May might be helpful if if I were
able to get everybody a copy of that not
all the appendices are in this uh but um
but this is what's this is what uh
recommendation 17 here was the question
should there be limits to how much a
charity can earn from its annual
engagement and here's the dialogue that
went on as the charitable Gaming
facilities increase in growth so will
the revenue individual Charities will
get in 2023 800 Charities benefited from
charitable gaming the commission
conducted a survey participating
Charities and learned that 91% uh of
sponsored Charities say that charitable
Gaming revenue is very important to
their organizational charit charitable
activities we also heard testimony from
Charities not yet involved in charitable
gaming indicating it was very difficult
to secure dates
from this discussion and earlier
discussions it became clear that the the
unavailability of dates the growing size
of earnings by those who have been
receiving dates the need to for
accountability of how charity spend
their earnings and how the Charities are
chosen to receive dates are all linked
together as that an issue that needs
further
study the concept introduced was having
a um I and I introduce this concept
perhaps we should look at uh at these
nonprofits from the based on their
mission based on what they do based on
where their monies go but we ran out of
time to finish that that research on
this so the so the commission agreed
that these issues needed further study
so here's the recommendation with that
the commission recommends that the
legislature vote to continue the to
study this issue via the proposed
creation of a joint committee of the
House and Senate shown and as
recommendation 25 in this
report so as it turns
out you folks have already passed
something and well out of this committee
16 to nothing to create another
commission or to continue the work of
the commission and this is kind of a
hybrid commission when I read this I
read this commission here uh UI
commission allows uh the the Senators
and in reps but then there's also
outside members and they also have a
vote this commission is different it
doesn't allow a vote which is fine but
it does have a representative from
Lottery and a representative from uh uh
AG's
office uh that get that or or
representative from those offices uh to
participate as members but I'll just
tell you that both of those this is an
aside both of those when we did this
report they were both Representatives on
the our commission chose not to vote
because they were state agencies that
didn't believe they should vote but
anyway you have a mechanism it's going
to be on the floor this week probably
going to pass um and I I strongly
recommend and let me let me just close
with this uh again I have the uppermost
regard for for representative Ames but
here's here's what my concerns are this
really hurts the large Charities that
depend on these revenues and we and
you're probably going to hear from some
of them uh that there are some that
really need 100,000 or 125,000 not
everybody does their missions are such
that they do this would harm those those
Charities if we pass this
bill and the fiscal note says that $18
million will be taken away from
Charities if you go to the fiscal note
on this and it and it go to the state
which means it's going to to go to the
education trust
fund
um it so that's something that we we
never contemplated we were trying to get
and the commission we were trying to get
more Charities involved how do we get
more Charities involved by trimming
making sure that we we weren't
overspending on it because there a long
list of Charities that are still trying
to get charitable gaming this is a
unique New Hampshire concept it's really
works that's why that's why I sponsor
the along with representative um duet
the historic racing machines the goal
was to make more Charities have more
Revenue available for more Charities and
we did double the number of Charities
that were involved from that bill
so um so again I think this is go to the
commission that was just formed to
really thoroughly look at this issue
thank you thank you representative
former representative abrami um and as U
commission chair of the charitable
Gaming Commission of which I was on as
well um it's it's good to hear from you
and I have I have can I address perp
andul you you read it right in the
statute this it says 50,000 for uh games
of chance and it says 50,000 for um um
charitable game uh for historic racing
the reason it's in two sections because
the statutes there's the there's the
games of chance statute and then there's
the uh racing statute and historic
racings in the racing statute uh but my
read of that is what I think your read
was that it would uh depending on how
much uh was generated any given of 10
days would be capped if for a charity be
tapped at 50,000 if it came from table
games and it'll be capped at 50,000 if
it came from historic racing games
that's the way I read it so thank you
thank you representative ducet thank you
Mr chair and just real briefly the the
uh as an aside the there's been an
amendment to the commission and both the
AG and the uh Lottery director are not
voting members okay if if it passes with
the amendment because of that concern we
had so in a nutshell you'd agree that
this is something that should be under
the purview of what I expect to be the
next charal gaming commission abut this
is this is one small component of right
a plethora of issues that have to be
addressed dates and how the dates are
selected how the charity is collected
how many days per charity and on and on
and on exactly yeah do dollars is part
of the comp and there were a lot of
other issues related to CH to U
charitable gaming that I'm not going to
bore you if you get the report you go to
work commit 25 there are a lot of issues
that need to be addressed still
including problem gambling uh things
like that that we we touched on we
actually had another uh consult we used
an consult outside consultant uh that
helped us uh with with all of this and
uh but I'm G leave it at that because
there's a lot of other people want to
speak elmy
you just a quick followup so would you
concur with my read on this that this
would change the model we have oh
absolutely change thank all right I
represent El me thank you uh I just want
to know what you mean by the 10.1% the
27.5 and the 62 oh that's that simply I
grouped the f i i that the
62% on you have though you've got the
percent of Charities that are getting
those different amounts right 34.7 next
to that you have 62 yeah that added the
first two so from 0 to 50,000 it was 62%
of the Charities of the Charities right
so 62 62% of the Charities make between
0 and 50,000
27.5% of the Charities make between
thank you 50 ,000 and and 100,000 and so
on and again on this chart that the
04 is represented it's three Charities
this was dated from
2023 two Charities that made around
about
155,000 each and then there was one that
made actually made
180,000 that was on there so again
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done on this and I I I think I think
representative Ames would agree that let
let's let this go to the commission to
vet thank you any other questions
representative om yeah thank you uh
former refer Ramy and thank you much for
your service on Ways and Means and your
wisdom on the whole process I have a
very difficult question I'd like to
ask our commission our committee is
designed to raise money for the general
fund to the benefit of New
Hampshire and the charge of our
commission is not necessarily to decide
the allocation of the fund we raise but
just try to raise as much we can and
turn over to people who are smarter than
us who can set these very very difficult
priorities and how to spend the limited
money that we have so my very tough
question is should we have any money at
all being designated through our tax law
going to Charities or should the
Charities compete for all the terrible
needs we have on an equal basis in the
finance committee so then it's simple we
might as well not call this charitable
gaming and uh again it's a unique model
uh again there's over 800 Charities now
that are involved good luck trying to
dismantle it okay I mean it's helping
too many too many organizations is
helping and again that's the way I got
involved in this it really does help a
lot of
organizations and uh remember the state
since we put historic racing in place
the revenue that the state I don't know
if I brought it with me here but the
revenue that the and I see
um commission the executive director uh
is here from Lottery uh he may be able
to speak to this but those revenues have
doubled tripled uh what goes to the
state it's it's it's all boats have been
raisen what what goes to the facilities
what goes to the Charities increased as
well as what goes to the state so um I I
don't think we really want to dismantle
this model
it it really does
work thank you uh representative
alberger thank you Mr chair thank you
for coming in today it was a pleasure to
meet you after having heard about you
for so long we met each other outside
yes um I'm trying to formulate the words
here because I'm trying to be clear
about my question so it I may stumble
through it a little
bit the charitable institutions that are
receiving funds through
gaming in part are doing the work
they're doing because the state is not
taking its responsibility to provide
those Services would would you agree
with that
statement for for some of them not all
of them okay
um I was going to say in my open remarks
that it's a misnomer that we're even
calling it charitable gaming it's really
not for-profit gaming because these are
not for profits a lot of the manaa
profits uh and it has a lot of the
501c uh
categories that are there that are all
over the place that's something else
that can be addressed we we started to
address it in the commission but you you
I gave you the list purposely so you
could just gaze and see the kind of
organizations that are being helped okay
and um uh you know this literally
responsibility of the state no but we're
helping a lot of little
leaks but is Easter Seals being helped
yes you know but every state that has
other Revenue more Revenue sources than
New Hampshire have all these things they
have all these na for profits that that
do good work so okay one one followup
and then um um I think we'll move on I
and I I noticed when I mentioned that
that a couple of the people in the
audience were
nodding I in addition I'm concerned
concerned
that we're not looking at vetting what
the services to the community are that
some of these organizations are getting
and was this part of what we're and I'm
specifically thinking about a group that
I really enjoyed listening to but I'm
not sure why we are supporting the New
Hampshire State Police bagpipe band
actually that that was in I think what I
just read in that issue was um number 17
it was uh
that I said the need for accountability
of how Chari spend their earnings is in
there as part of what should be looked
you okay
um and I know that was a long two
minutes that I let uh former
representative talk but he you know
being the chair of that commission I
think it was valuable to hear uh his
Insight on that um so I would like to U
keep people to two minutes and again the
19 remaining cards I have you are all
against this bill just so you know okay
good
morning my name is Michelle Ali and I am
the CEO of Webster house Children's Home
in Manchester New
Hampshire I'm testifying in opposition
of HB
531 for the past 141 years since
1884 the Webster house has been
providing a safe supportive home for
children unable to live at home for
reasons of abuse neglect addiction and
other challenges in the community we are
contract with the Department of Health
and Human Services and have children
between the ages of 8 and 18 living at
the house they are primarily referred to
us through
DCF based on our contract we receive a
daily rate from the state which covers
only
50% of our
expenses that said it is so critical
that we close the funding Gap with
revenue streams including grants individ
ual and corporate donations and
thankfully charitable
gaming we nurture these atrisk youth
through trauma informed care we provide
stability and structure while rebuilding
self-esteem confidence and independent
living
skills we take these kids to school
appointments fund social activities
celebrate birthdays graduations and
holidays with them just like we do with
our own
children the charitable gaming funds are
critical to the web house they help us
provide the highest level of care for
our residents giving them a home filled
with healthy food appropriate clothing
and all of the basic needs that build
their trust happiness confidence and
enable them to thrive every child
deserves a second chance to experience
the joys of
childhood we're so grateful for
charitable gaming funds without that we
would have to eliminate some of the
initiatives that POS that positively
impact our children These funds are well
established in our budget and we rely on
them to close our funding
Gap HB 531 would put Charities like ours
at risk I strongly urge you to reject HB
531 I'm responsible for the kids that
live in our home and I want to continue
doing that for many years to come thank
you so much thank you uh represent
elme yes could you tell me
gamble good question um they are all
under the year the age of 18 and they do
not get all of the freedoms as your
average teenager they don't have um free
reign to uh technology or cell phones
or you know laptops without our care we
have to be in their care 24 hours a day
so no they're definitely not gaming on
our watch and we would highly highly um
be against that thank
you seeing no more questions thank you
very
H your microphone isn't
morning my name is bran
Madden I am from delber New Hampshire
and I am the founder and chairman of the
nonprofit
organization the New Hampshire Coalition
for the support of service dogs we are
committed to the education and advocacy
about service dogs as well as providing
financial aid for that bills for service
dos for residents of New
Hampshire and
setting uh setting limits on the
amount of annual of a turle
gaming would greatly reduce the amount
of good the nonprofit Community can
contribute to the
Amy
hollingworth hello members of the Ways
and Means Committee and members of the
public my name is Amy hollingworth and I
am the executive director here
representing our small nonprofit
nhmi um in testifying an opposition of
House Bill
531 nhmi is recognized in Southern New
Hampshire for its Community faed program
called the safe Sports Network which
addresses the athletic healthc care
needs um and Health Equity of
school-aged athletes to highlight some
of the uh Services provided by safe
Sports Network in our state we C
coordinate healthc care services on the
sidelines during newth Sports contests
and
nhiaa Championship events we conduct
Baseline testing and uh concussion
management um especially in gaps like
middle schools where there isn't that
for thousands of youths and Adolescence
um each year we provide dedicated
athletic trainers at eight high schools
in Southern New Hampshire and we operate
a free or pro bono uh athletic training
clinic in southern downtown New
Hampshire uh Manchester New Hampshire
our work also encompasses middle school
programs Community Education and
emergency prepared initiatives around
the southern part of the
state um importantly our program uh
funds 70 is 70% funded by Community um
and we our budget being just under a
million dollar budget we provide the
services about 5 to 600 thou about
$600,000 of our services are provided
for free to our schools and our kids uh
and family
community um so this charitable gaming
funding not only ensures reliable
financial support uh and predictable
times for us throughout the year but it
also has allowed us to expand our
resources so as you know we provide and
prepare our budgets based on you know um
our knowledgeable but guesses of uh
historical of what we've had for
services so we've grown from our start
30 years ago helping a handful of kids
on the sidelines at a Friday night
football game to helping nearly 600
6,000 students in Southern New Hampshire
with our sideline care and our AR clinic
so those Services have been expanded
based on our increased amount of um
uh Revenue that we've been able to get
and inart from charitable gaming so I um
would ask you please to um reject House
Bill
no red light there we
go hello members of the house and ways
committee my name is Lily Wellington I
am the director of volunteer services at
the friends program I work and reside in
conquered I could start by hitting you
over the head with the impact of our
small nonprofit but I'm not going to do
that I'm going to start by telling you
Margaret
story Margaret called our office on a
Monday afternoon nearly in tears the
86-year-old woman explained that she
could see conquered Hospital from the
window of her home but she simply could
not get there three times a week for
dialysis she'd done everything right she
saved her retirement she stayed close to
Community Resources she stayed socially
connected her husband passed away her
friends aged and she had to make the
decision to take herself off the
road she needed help getting to her
medical
appointments and she relied as so many
New Hampshire citizens do on an informal
support I can see the hill I just can't
us there are thousands of Margarets
across New
Hampshire they rely on nonprofits to
live full
and healthy lives we answered Margaret's
call for
help we put out Margaret's request for 6
a.m dialysis treatment three times a
week and in one day one day we were able
to secure her ride three times a week to
and from dialysis for the next six
months that is through a volunteer
network of drivers that takes one staff
person to coordinate
life our nonprofit serves more than
30,000 Margarets a year they need food
they need Transportation they need
thank you very much good morning my name
is Michael Goodwin from marac New
Hampshire I'm representing Granite State
Independent Living I'm I'm the uh
development director there and I like to
just share my thoughts and concerns on
House Bill 531 I've had the great uh
Fortune of leading several nonprofits
since 2000 I was actually part in New
Hampshire and I was actually part of the
first ever charitable gaming night at
Rockingham Park
and I've got to see this grow over that
time and the money raised for nonprofits
around the states obviously had a
tremendous impact uh more than anything
that the state could provide us you know
the money is making positive changes for
so many of our citizens as you know
charities in this room and Charities
around the state rely on this Revenue to
support the great work that's being done
directly in our local communities and
around the state many Charities that
have a direct impact on making positive
changes in their Community such as YMCAs
boys and girls girl clubs mental health
organizations elderly service providers
Meals on Wheels disability services and
all the great Charities that are in this
room um they've been able to grow and
increase services to their communities
and address some of the most critical
issues that a lot of you face every day
in those seats some of those include
homelessness substance misuse mental
health Child Care Suicide Prevention and
a lot more than that other service
organizations such as quanas rotary kns
of Columbus those types of organizations
um they might not have a direct impact
on their communities but those
organizations that used to raise $5,000
a year through bake sales and Raffles
are now making a lot more money that
they then support local charities and
have a much bigger impact so those
dollars are increasing in many different
ways and really truly making a
difference so um now those organizations
like those uh can make a Luder impact
because they've been participating in
the games a chance uh Granite State
Independent Living iates through the
Lebanon po poker room we currently don't
fall into this category yet we hope to
um you know but that in the near future
but the funds we raise go directly into
the many services we provide to people
with disabilities throughout the state
it helps with transportation services
Transitional Care Home modifications and
peer service and that's just a few of
the 19 programs that we offer uh if we
were fortunate to be in that category um
like many of the other nonprofits I'd
hope that we would be able to retain
that money and invest it back into the
life-changing programs um that we offer
in same way many of the other Charities
are able to do something that can't be
overlooked is that the great work being
done around the state of New Hampshire
helps our government um to address the
needs of its citizens in a way that the
state budget doesn't always allow
nonprofits are the lifeblood of our
citizens and we view our role as uh
nonprofits in this room and around the
state as a way to help our legislators
solve problems and address issues if GS
and other nonprofits were limited in our
ability to maximize our revenue from
sources like charitable gaming would
have a drastic impact on the citizens
you all represent if the estimate of1
18,600 per year is accurate best
utilization of those dollars um the
nonprofits that are in the trenches
addressing the best use of those dollars
would be the nonprofits that are in the
trenches addressing those issues facing
our citizens I ask that you deeply uh
consider the impact that this bill could
have on the work and nonprofits do that
we do day in and day out make New
Hampshire one of the the best states to
live in our country thank
Harrington hi um thank you very much for
giving us the opportunity to present um
our Harington yes y better okay
thanks thank you um
yes I wish I was as well spoken as the
folks previous to me but um I come from
Catamount woman Aid to represent um our
eight member volunteer board we started
in
2011 um because a social worker in our
community identified a need where um
there were gaps in you know immediate
needs that families and folks in the um
area needed so we try to provide local
people with emergency financial
assistance that's not ready not readily
available through other resources and we
are very much a Grassroots
nonprofit um our primary focus um
initially was to assist individuals and
families in Barnstead Deerfield Epsom
Pittsfield North Northwood and straford
but the need is really um amazingly our
eyes are open to the need throughout the
state where there are not organizations
like ours and so we um partner with all
communities to provide as much
assistance as we can so it's not limited
to our original area of uh help um let
need my glasses for um prior to
charitable gamings help our funding was
extremely tight um we were limited to
small individual donations and in an
annual 5K event that um brought in maybe
a couple thousand dollars so we really
didn't have a a lot of um opportunity to
do the Outreach and meet as many needs
as we wanted
to um I'll give you an example of uh a
family that we were able to help or
families actually there were three
families in a nearby community who are
recently forced from their homes due to
a fire in a multif family building
because Catamount woman a has funds from
charitable gaming it allowed us to react
quickly and provide assistance for their
most immediate basic needs for um
clothing food Etc without the funds from
charitable gaming we will very likely
have to turn away some requests and
minimize the help that we can
offer um we and many other nonprofit
organizations are extremely grateful for
what the charitable gaming funds have
allowed us to provide for New Hampshire
families and we see more and more people
in need this is a very um we are able to
be very Nimble we have um created some
great relationships with organizations
um I respectfully oppose HB 531 and
would hope that um you hear what we're
K can you hear me good morning my name
is Erica Kaa and I'm the Executive Vice
President for New Hampshire soccer
association I am here testifying an
opposition of House Bill 531 New
Hampshire soccer association provides
service and program for Youth and adults
throughout our state we currently serve
50 15,000 members and with world cup
2026 coming our numbers could
potentially double soccer is not just
about physical activity they're about
fostering resilience self-con
self-confidence and mental health in
today's world many young people are
facing increased stress anxiety and
other mental health challenges soccer
along with other sports offers an outlet
for these pressures helping children and
teens build coping skills form
supportive relationships and develop
positive mindsets however the cost of
par participation can be a barrier for
some families by utilizing charitable
gaming we can reduce these Financial
obstacles charitable gaming has allowed
us to scholarship athletes that wouldn't
normally be able to afford to play we
are able to create new adaptive
programming such as ampute soccer blind
soccer as well as expand our current top
soccer programming top soccer is for
children with disabilities these
programs allow us to be allinclusive
within the local soccer Community House
Bill 531 would put organ organiz ations
like ours at risk we are a nonprofit who
rely on these funds to serve our members
our members and clubs are also nonprofit
we try to keep our costs low in order to
give opportunities to kids to play the
beautiful game of soccer I respectively
urge you to consider the broad benefits
of charitable gaming in supporting these
important programs locally it's a
positive impact on Mental Health Youth
Development Youth Development and
Community engagement thank you thank
you uh next I have John
tant and I apologize if that's not
pronounced
properly thank you uh Mr chair and that
was not a uh poor pronunciation I'll
accept it um and honorable representativ
is bonjour I'm I'm the executive
director of the Franco americ Center
here in New Hampshire we uh celebrate
French language culture and Heritage and
uh offering French classes for Youth and
adults at all levels of language
learning and organizing social and
cultural events uh roughly 23% of the
population of New Hampshire has French
or French Canadian Heritage so uh we've
got a lot of people we're trying to
serve but um with regard to this bill
I'm I'm hoping that in the interest of
my brevity I will score some points with
you um it is an opposition there's two
aspects of the bill that I'd like to
touch on that I don't think that uh have
been touched on yet uh one of them is um
with regard to the money uh the Surplus
over the
$50,000 going into the state trust fund
that uh is for education and it would
change the concept of charitable gaming
to the concept of charitable and
educational gaming uh and help to fund
education in a way that would um perhaps
um take away from our nonprofit
community that needs it so much uh the
second piece is that the bill would uh
as written go into effect uh on July 1st
uh that would uh essentially take and uh
half the nonprofits in the state that
are in the third and fourth quarters and
penalize them while favoring the first
two quarters of the year so I would ask
that if you did choose to move forward
with some version that you look at
moving the date for Effective Beyond
this year the 2025 year uh thank you
very much for your time and uh the
difficult decisions that you deal with
Roa morning again uh Tom do roza with um
principal at Main Street strategic we uh
represent the New Hampshire Center for
nonprofits uh and here in opposition to
HP 531
uh the center is a nonprofit
organization we have more than 800
members dedicated to strengthening and
amplifying the voice of New Hampshire's
nonprofit sector through leadership
collaboration and learning opportunities
and in the interest of time I will not
repeat what has been heard and what you
will continue to hear I do want to
emphasize as former representative
abrami stated already uh we need to
recognize New Hampshire does not have
legalized gaming in the traditional
sense right instead our state allows
gaming exclusively when it is sponsored
by charitable organizations we need to
consider consider that when we think
about the logic of the state limiting
the nonprofit sponsoring entities of the
activity that they legally made
available to the public so for that
everything you've heard and will
continue to hear uh we respectfully urge
you
I'll try to be as quick as Flight of the
Bumblebee so I'm Terry dco I'm live in
Derry I am representing the New
Hampshire philarmonic which is a
nonprofit that benefits from the
charitable gaming obviously you know I'm
in opposition to the bill so I'm just
going to read our statement live
classical music is important to the
communities of New Hampshire our
nonprofit the New Hampshire philarmonic
has been in operation since
1905 live music gives everyone involved
a sense of
community the support from charitable
gaming allows us to keep ticket prices
affordable to all New Hampshire
residents they so they are able to
experience a full live Symphony
Orchestra without having to travel to
Boston if charitable gaming funds are
limited we would have to continually
raise ticket prices due to the increas
cost of renting a venue to perform and
rehearse our 100 plus orchestral
musicians board members staffs and
volunteers travel to Salem every week to
give back to the communities of New
Hampshire most of our playing members
are volunteers ranging from high school
students to older adults that played
instruments all their lives we have many
members who have played with the Phil as
high school students and have come back
to play as adults and a few that have
gone on to have successful music careers
with the BSO and the met in New York
City we also are a teaching Orchestra we
bring in students from the surrounding
area high school college whoever would
like to come and they can sit next to
and be mentored by other members of the
orchestra we have many professional
musicians that also Play and music
educators from across the state we have
a drawn to music program in col
collaboration with New Hampshire school
teachers and students to Pro provide a
free experience for students and
teachers and parents to watch the fil
perform the students listen and learn
about a selected piece of music this
year it's gusta halts the planets and
then are asked to create artwork that
goes along with the music the teachers
then submit the drawings to the fill and
the students are given free tickets to
hear a live concert while the
interpretive drawings are displayed on a
big screen during the concert for a
truly unique multimedia experience for
many children it's the first time
they've ever heard a live Symphony
Orchestra this collaboration experience
would not be possible without the
charitable gaming funds please vote no
to these bills thank you on behalf of
the New Hampshire Orchestra volunteer
uh next I have
I think I BR the last name but uh I'm
I'm getting good at trying to read uh
people's writing no worries thank you
very
much uh good morning members of the
committee chair um I'm Mike appleberg
with the United Way of great and ASA um
we're here of course as well as all my
friends in the back opposing HB
531 just a couple of quick points
while we do understand the intentions
behind regulating charitable gaming we
believe that HP 531 will have very
significant negative unintended
consequences for the many organizations
that rely heavily on these funds by
capping the revenue of $50,000 a year we
believe that this bill is effectively a
tax on the nonprofit
sector in fact it's a tax to the tune of
$18.6 million which would be siphoned
out of the sector and put back into the
state's offers charitable organizations
play crucial role in addressing various
social issues as you've heard including
poverty education healthc Care and More
New Hampshire nonprofits have a
tremendous impact in our communities
providing essential Services creating
jobs and fostering a sense of community
limiting their funding will hinder their
efforts and negatively impact the lives
of those dep that depend on all of our
services additionally we do not believe
that that siphoning off these funds from
the nonprofit sector into the general
fund aligns with the original purpose
and intent of charitable gaming in the
state of New
Hampshire if as representative Ames
stated the purpose is to be more
Equitable with regards to the
organizations that benefit from
charitable gaming why would we in fact
take those funds out of the sector
altogether that makes absolutely no
sense given these concerns we
respectfully request that the committee
vote HP 531 in expedient to legislate
and we urge you to consider the broader
implications of this Bill thank you for
your your time and attention in this
matter if you have any questions I'd be
glad to take those and I'm not surprised
to see representative Aly represent
light go on hi representative good
morning uh
given well if Lebanon is any uh example
of this the amount of problem gaming is
going way up because of this this
activity uh would you feel the same way
if the money was used
to understand and do something about the
problem gaming
situation thank you for your question I
cannot comment on the status of problem
gaming in Lebanon my community is
Southern Hampshire Southern H Hillsboro
County however before coming up here
today I did consult with my good friends
from greater Nashville mental health
about problem gaming in our community
they have seen no uptick no measurable
uptick in gaming problems in our
community community and the need for
services um I don't know if it's
different in other parts of the state
but we're not seeing that in our
community thank you thank you uh in my
community we see it through the uh
poverty and centers representative Spar
thank you chair um the uh um list that
uh we got here with the 800 or so uh
Charities that are benefiting from the
uh the current system there're roughly
9500 tax exempt organizations in the
state of New Hampshire uh 8,700 roughly
than are not benefiting from this
program uh if that cap and as Mr as
representative ases has the balance
anything over the 50,000 goes back to
the Lottery Commission if it were to be
spread out to other nonprofits would you
be open to that well that's actually
been talked about and of course you know
United Way United ways across the
country started as Community funds for
ially the purpose of Distributing um
funding to nonprofits in their
communities um I think that's a that's a
worthy topic to take up I don't we are
not opposed to the cap per se we're
opposed to taking funds out of the
sector what you're suggesting is
absolutely a possibility and something
we and I'm sure many other nonprofits
would be glad to be part of that
you one more question from R shamber
thank you Mr chairman thank you sir for
taking this you probably can speak for
all the
organizations uh all this money that is
uh uh one in these
casinos uh charitable gaming do you do
audits to and do you publish your audits
from the money that is uh won there and
is the public allowed to review those
audits well every um so every
nonprofit is either subject to audit or
not subject audit based on their annual
revenues our revenues as are many of
those colleagues behind me are in fact
large enough to have public Audits and
audit records our audit we believe in
transparency to the painful extreme our
two audits if you'd care to review those
are on our website um for the past two
years as long as as well as our
um Financial records unitedway nw.org
thank you sir thank you get one more
question represent will U comparing to
all of the not for-profits it's my
understanding that 990 forms need to be
filed by all of them if they're uh
federally registered or they generate WR
any revenue of any kind I know that the
organization that organizations to which
I belong are required to file
990s is that your understanding as well
well 990 is it's just like the 1040 is a
person right there's a 990 and there's
like a short form 990 for smaller
organizations we file the standard 990
um that's part of being a
501c3 thank you sir thank you thank you
very much all right I have H several
copies I'll just pass that up to you
sounds
good morning my name is Susan Ford I am
the executive director of my friend's
place uh homeless shelter and
transitional housing program in New
Hampshire uh we are in Dober we're a
small agency uh we're a $500,000 budget
agency Bare Bones we serve upwards of 30
people every day men women and children
this bill would our agency we
are contracted with the state and the
state gives us $27 a day it costs us $55
a day to serve individuals so we have to
fund raise the balance of that
charitable gaming which includes Bingo
we last year took in
$135,000 if we have if we that was
capped at
$50,000 we would not be able to serve
the people that we serve and
unfortunately our agency isn't uh
although it is kind of warm and fuzzy
it's crucial people will die if we're
not there especially in the temperatures
that we're seeing right now I can't
express how much this bill would crucify
our
good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity uh my name is Chris Thompson
uh born and raised in New Hampshire
currently live in Bennington New
Hampshire I currently serve on three
nonprofit boards in the State uh the
makea Wish Foundation of New Hampshire
Elliot Perry foundation and Elliot
hospitals Pearl Manor fund I stand
before you today not representing any of
those nonprofits
but rather as a voice to the thousands
of nonprofits in New Hampshire and the
dedicated volunteers and philanthropists
that support those organizations as
everyone knows charitable gaming is a
major funding source for many nonprofits
in New Hampshire countless Charities
rely on charitable gaming to fund
programs and support those in need and
today that mission critical Revenue
stream is at risk for the Charities and
most importantly for the vulnerable
citizens uh that rely on those Charities
I was personally involved in helping the
make A- Wish Foundation of New Hampshire
start the process of engaging in
charitable G charitable gaming in 2020
and since then uh revenue from
charitable gaming donations for make
aish specifically has increased every
year funds from charitable gaming
directly impacted our ability to grant
wishes to over 30 children with
life-threatening medical conditions the
revenue from charitable gaming has
become a critical component of our
annual budget and it's allowed us to
fulfill our mission and reach more
children in need House Bill 531 will
have a profoundly negative impact on
nonprofits and most importantly the
people that we serve and that's an
unfortunate
situation uh the limit of
$50,000 um is ultimately the state of
New Hampshire taking Revenue away from
critical nonprofits who serve the
community and it destroys the work the
Charities have put into their strategy
to secure revenue from charitable gaming
organizations this would be catastrophic
to New Hampshire Charities and those
they serve to representative Ames who
sponsored this bill in no way does uh
house bill 530 1 represent the selfless
philanthropic people in New Hampshire
that I know thank you for the
Jr thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee um so much has been said
I've reduced about half of what I
intended to say so hopefully I'll be
brief uh my name is Terry Highland Jr
I'm from straford New Hampshire and I'm
here representing kemples Brain Injury
center in
Portsmith um we are a nonprofit Human
Services organization uh and for 25
years kemples has been dedicated to
improving the quality of life for
individuals living with an acquired
brain injury uh our Center is like no
other and unlike many most postacute
programs we support individuals long
after their insurances have stopped
doing so um ongoing Rehabilitation is
something that this state and this
country as a whole do not uh tend to
make a priority for folks kemples will
never turn anyone away due to inability
to pay one of our current members
actually attends the program for free
and has been doing so for 23
years uh at crimes we offer habilitative
evidence-based programs that Foster
social interaction Life Training skills
mental and physical supports um and
Recreation opportunities for individuals
who have experienced severe brain trauma
as mentioned our services are always
financially accessible to anyone who
would benefit in fact kemes underwrites
nearly
$300,000 in either reduced or free
attendance every year we're deeply
concerned about House Bill 531 for kmle
$50,000 cap would result in a loss of
over
$110,000 in annual funding for our
organization yes this is the highest
number of charitable gaming funds we've
ever been allocated the previous year
was 990,000 the previous year before
that was 60,000 we are seeing our
partner the brook have record revenues
that being said with the highest ever
allocation this year to us it is also
the highest budget deficit year that we
are budgeting everybody's expenses are
going
up so this significant reduction would
directly impact our ability to deliver
these vital Services potentially leading
to program Cuts or limitations on the
number of individuals we can
serve um speeding up here the
distribution is a really key part of our
income uh 85% philanthropically funded
we do not receive very much uh revenue
from other income streams less than 10%
from any state services including
disability
waivers so all of us here uh speaking
for the room understand the need for the
state to manage these resources
effectively however we urge you to
consider the broader implications of
this bill with New Hampshire's historic
Reliance on nonprofits to provide these
needed Human
Services um in conclusion we ask for you
to go ahead and oppose and we'll also be
speaking to 588 later so I'll get out of
you uh let's
see Kane Kane K it's Kane under it's
okay and thank you Mr chairman and thank
you members of the
committee four my name is Kevin
underiner I'm a resident of do New
Hampshire and I'm here speaking in
opposition to House Bill
531 so you've heard lots of stories from
from many people people about how
they're benefiting from the funds so I
won't go into specifics in that regard
so very quickly I suffered a major
stroke five and a half years ago I was
told i' never walk again I walk poorly
now but I do walk and I relied on
certain agencies primarily kle Center
and project walk which is in stratum to
get a life back after a
stroke with regard to house Bell 531 I
understand the complexity with
allocating charitable
funds doing it in the manner that this
bill proposes I'm against that and I
would urge the committee to look at
doing something more timely look at
doing something that takes a little bit
more time into effect so that budgets
you've heard that this will affect
budgets so budgets are addressed so that
things can be done more in a more stable
way that doesn't affect organizations
dramatically 27 years ago I moved to New
Hampshire I'm sorry 25 years ago I moved
to New Hampshire and at that time New
Hampshire was amongst the lowest states
in the country for charitable giving we
are now I think at number 24 that is
really awesomely good considering the
the economic Times you're living in
based on that and based on this bill if
we allocate and limit these funds that
are charitable funds if they go into the
state funding for the Lottery Commission
New Hampshire will no longer be number
24 in the state in the country for
charitable giving so I think that the
challenge that you have is what do you
do with limited charitable funds and I
think that a better way of doing it
would take more input from the community
and a little more time and especially
don't do something right in the middle
of a calendar year thank you very much
and any questions
thank
much um Aon um
beur good
afternoon so my name is Aaron fairhurst
and I am the program director for the
kmes Brain Injury center which as you've
heard is a nonprofit organization that
serves uh survivors of acquired brain
injury our organization is based in
Portsmouth New Hampshire but with our
online program we serve residents
throughout the state of New
Hampshire our members range in ages from
about 20 years old to 877 years
old like Kevin they have all experienced
sudden life-changing Medical events that
have completely disrupted their
lives they are businessmen they are
contractors they are healthc Care
Professionals it experts Etc whose lives
have been turned upside down for 25
years the kemples Brain Injury center
has provided these members with
postacute therapeutic programming
focused on social and communication
skills cognitive skill building physical
wellness mental health and
community members participate in groups
of their choice depending on their needs
and their preferences member-driven
member choice is an aspect of our
organization that we take great pride in
unlike medical models the kemples Brain
Injury center does not dictate frequency
or duration of attending our
program instead members choose their
level of participation based on their
own individual needs and their own
goals Beyond this programming and
perhaps most importantly the kemples
Brain Injury center provides its members
with a safe and a welcoming
Community this community becomes a
foundation for members to have the
confidence and the support to discover
and reinvent themselves post injury
members have shared with me that kmle
Brain Injury center was the reason that
they got out of bed and that it has been
a Lifeline to them as they begin
again as Terry mentioned k Brain Injury
center does not turn anyone away due to
their inability to pay this is possible
in part because of the funding that we
receive from New Hampshire charitable
gaming which is roughly $150,000
annually a loss of this funding would
directly impact our ability to deliver
highquality programming and essential
supports and services to our members
likely resulting in a limitation on
offerings Andor the number of
individuals that we can
serve I'm here today to strongly urge
the committee to oppose House Bill
531 this this opposition will allow kmle
Brain Injury center and other nonprofits
alike to continue to provide supports
and services to those in need and to
continue to strengthen New Hampshire
communities thank you thank
you chair Yeah question
yes thank you I would you oh please
return like to ask a ask you a question
thank you thank you for taking my
question kmle uh Center I'm familiar
with and it seems like you have a pretty
organized uh presentation group here
today which is terrific
uh and you may or may not be able to
answer this but I'm curious to know how
what effort it took to get kemples on
the
list of the
brook and how
long that took if it and what sort of
effort you put in
to uh get that and then I have a
followup for that I'm going to turn that
over to Terry whose development and
fine thank you for your
question uh rep representative Malloy um
It's a Wonderful question I'm glad I get
the opportunity to address it so kmes
has been partnering with the brook since
2011 at that time we were getting paper
checks once weekly and the total of 10
consecutive days of gaming was around
$14,000 um because we were so early in
the application process um we have been
able to maintain that relationship uh
with the brook that said staff turnover
uh in both locations has been an ongoing
threat to that relationship and it is an
annual question mark on if the funding
will continue so I want to make sure
that it's clear that we do not rely on
this in our budget it is uh something
that we hope for thoroughly Mr chair
followup thank you anticipated my next
question uh I want to be a little more
specific how do you intend to maintain
that
relationship the
future so the brook um is is very candid
with us on their expectations of being a
charitable gaming partner we um are
making sure that we acknowledge their
efforts uh around every corner and turn
over every stone we can uh with the
press and um you know highlighting their
good work and they ask this of all their
charitable partners and it's a very fair
ask the year in January where we submit
a report of what we did with last year's
funds and then we discuss back and forth
on if it will be 10 days again when
those days are it's all question mark
every year but it is a conversation
between the partners and I think all
these organizations would share that
with their gaming organizations um
nothing's guaranteed it is a
mle hi I'm Anne Michael and I'm with um
fueled by kids and I'm testifying in
opposition to H B
531 um I'm part of the fuel by kids
organization which is a nonprofit that
my daughter started when she was in high
school to provide weekend food bags for
kids in
Manchester in 2016 we started providing
about 65 bags at one school and over the
course of um these past years we've
grown to serve 21 schools in Manchester
and we do 1130 bags a week
um this uh basically we don't have any
um employees it's all
volunteers and our uh budget is about
$235,000 that we'll spend on the food
this year um 35% of that comes from our
charitable gaming um donations and just
quickly um if there was a limit uh we
we've started in 2020 and we had about
$60,000 in 2020 this year it uh this
past year was
$85,000 so that's
$35,000 um if there was a cap at $50,000
that basically provides six weeks of our
uh weekend food bags for the kids in
Manchester or another way to look at it
is 175 kids um for the whole year so um
obviously that's an important part of
our um budget and I just wanted to say
um that I strongly urge you to reject
you okay I have
two good I can't read the last part of
your name Jane good
your so I wrote this yesterday did not
know I had 2 minutes um much of what has
been said you know I agree with can you
state your name oh I'm sorry Jane
Goodman Goodman okay yeah the ending is
Chicken Scratch sorry about that um I'm
the executive director of the NASA soup
kitchen and shelter and our mission is
to provide food and shelter with dignity
to individuals and families in need
while promoting a path to Independence
through Direct Services and Partnerships
Partnerships with many of the nonprofits
that have already spoken today we're
dedicated to serving some of the most
vulnerable members of our community
so I appreciate the opportunity to speak
with you today about the potential
impact of HB
531 last year our organization received
nearly $100,000 in charitable gaming
proceeds so I guess we're in that second
group not that top top group funding
that is critical to our ability to
provide shelter meals and essential
services to those in need in an annual
budget of $3 million this is a
significant sum that directly trans
translates into assistance for
struggling individuals and Families Our
Revenue sources are diverse but fragile
we receive approximately 12% of our
budget from State funding um that was
mentioned about $27 per bedight costs
over $50 per bed night we're funded for
46 of our beds by the state we have over
80 beds every
night um so those costs just don't go
away 5% from Grants and Foundations
5% from rental income and 53% from
contributions and donations while
private donations are our largest
revenue stream fundraising is always an
ongoing challenge nonprofits like ours
are in constant competition for donor
attention and economic uncertainties
only make it more difficult to secure
sustained sustained support furthermore
in the current federal environment there
is a looming risk of losing additional
funding whether due to cuts at the
federal level or reductions in funds
passed down to States every dollar we
receive is carefully allocated to
provide Direct Services and the loss of
charitable gaming proceeds would create
a gap that would be difficult if not
impossible to fill redirecting nonprofit
Gaming revenue to the New Hampshire lot
Lottery Commission does not strengthen
our communities it weakens them
organizations like ours and many of my
peer nonprofits that are here today rely
on this funding to meet essential needs
that would otherwise fall to State and
local governments instead of taking
resources away from nonprofits we should
be working together to ensure that
charitable gaming continues to serve the
very purpose it was designed for
supporting vital work in our community I
urge you to oppose this legislation and
protect this essential funding source
for nonprofits across the state thank
you for your time thank you for your
Alis you got it right it's AMD just like
Jaws like Amityville every horror movie
I swear I'm not a
nightmare I'm here I'm actually not a
not for-profit I am an accounting firm
owner that only Services nonprofits and
I'm the only one in the state of New
Hampshire so I come here with a lot of
experience in seeing the day-to-day
impact of charitable gaming for the
nonprofits in our state um I would say
for a lot of the small organizations
charitable gaming is 20 to 40% of their
entire budget so if we take that away
from them it's going to have serious
consequences on the community in the
state of New Hampshire um I did provide
you a letter with some more information
if that's helpful and you're welcome to
contact me and talk 990s
anytime um but I just wanted to be here
to kind of give a voice from the outside
that gets to see on a day-to-day I love
my job um what the positive impact is of
charitable gaming is in the state and
how many different types of resources it
creates and I also wanted to point out
too that right now um I didn't sleep
last week I don't know about any of you
but um a lot of my not for-profits were
not able to access their federal funds
last week uh the cost of living in the
CATE of New Hampshire has grown and
giving is down so this leads to the huge
impact of charitable gaming has created
to help with budget deficits in the
state of New Hampshire for
nonprofits um the other thing is is that
the state is taking longer to pay in
certain situations and the Saving Grace
has been charitable gaming literally
we've had conversations saying that you
know maybe you should join charitable
gaming to help build that extra 30 days
of cash because it's now taking 60 days
to get paid a lot of nonprofits don't
have another 30 days of cash just
sitting around so charitable gaming has
been a Lifeline for a lot of
organizations in the state in the past
few years and they've contributed a lot
of time and effort as some folks have
pointed out in the lines to get into
some of these locations and facilities
and get on the lists so respectfully I
oppose this bill I'm available for
questions at any time and thank you so
much for your service thank you very
much now that's all I have for pin cards
is there someone who has not testified
who did not fill out a pin card who who
would like to
speak seeing none I will close the
okay
now trying to figure out how we're going
to do the rest of our schedule here um I
think what we're going to do is the
committee is going to take a half hour
lunch break instead of an hour lunch
break we'll cut it to 1 half hour I'll
ask committee members to be back here at
uh 1:00 sharp because we will start um
and we'll start at 1:00 on HB
588 I have 14 pink cards on that one um
we I think we underestimated the uh the
interest in both these bills um but
we're doing our best to um to make it
work so so one o00 HB 588 and then when
that's done we'll go to HP 591
and the exact session will happen after
understanding
okay
e
okay the time being 105 uh we're going
to get started I'm going to open the
public hearing on HB
588 and uh invite representative Sally
bill good afternoon Mr chairman uh
committee members my name is Sally
fellows I represent the towns of Ashlin
holderness impl
this bill is a proposal to bring more
historic horse racing Revenue into the
education trust fund it does it does not
tap table game revenues going to Charity
New Hampshire has licensed charitable
Gaming facilities since
2006 for table games such as Roulette in
21 profits are split between the casino
operator in Charities with a very small
portion going to the Lottery Commission
to cover administrative
expenses recently there have been two
significant developments that directly
impact charitable
Revenue in May of
2022 the roll out of historic horse
racing machines which resemble slot
machines
began hundreds are already in place
and more will be added as new and
renovated casinos
expand in Ju the second thing that has
happened is in July of
2023 the single wager limit for table g
games increased from $10 to
$50 gaming profits for operators and
skyrocketed the fiscal note shows this
bill will decrease FY 26 revenue for
Charities but when you use
prehistoric horse rating data which
would be
fy22 for
comparison they will um they will take a
dip but they will quickly return to that
level and then surpass that
Benchmark as noted in the f note of the
previous bill that you heard
hb31 the Lottery Commission expects
Casino profits to incre increase quote
future this
um this reasonable rate that that the
the re this this this bill will let the
charity revenues incre increase at a
reasonable rate and also at the same
time provide $25 million for the next
bium budget of the state I hope you will
support this
Bill thank you
questions oh I think representative duet
question GE thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I do correct
me if I'm wrong but this basically would
rewrite the platform we have in
charitable gaming we have charitable
gaming this this would I mean part and
parcel of the
HHR uh the Advent of HHR was us having
the ability to add yet another charity
to the Daily
gaming um so this is a you know total
rewrite of what we've passed we've lived
through the years where normal gaming
didn't pass we have a model that's
working for charitable gaming I
understand that there's issues with
other components of of the state budget
but tell me why that this makes sense
well as I stated um charitable gaming
started in 2006 with table games and so
how long did we go 15 years or so with
that model with the Charities operating
off table games a lot of the the
Charities that we heard testify on the
last Bill said that they've been
receiving their money for a very long
time one of them mentioned
2011 so this the historic um horse
racing is it's in a different statute
than the table games and um I I really
don't think that in 2006 and anybody was
thinking about historical horse racing
in the state of New Hampshire so I just
think that um this proposal continues
what's been in in place for almost 20
years and still allows Charities to
they'll they'll get more money the the
data shows us that the historical horse
racing putting those in the casinos has
drawn in more people that spend money on
the historical horse racing machines and
they also are spending more money on the
table games which this bill does not
touch follow
up just I'm going to be real brief there
there's a history of this legislature
supporting gaming or not supporting
gaming this legislature in years past
moved past normal Casino operations for
the benefit of the state
we have a a charitable gaming model
right now that a component is
HHR in and I I forgive me representative
fellows I don't know if you were here
during the HHR debate part of that
component was adding yet another charity
to the pool of Charities that can
benefit from charitable gaming we don't
have a a model everything that was done
was to benefit the Charities at the end
of the day it wasn't to benefit the
education trust fund this is a a a
rewrite of Statute this this this let me
let me continue my
question the question is what my
question is what for what purpose do you
want to rewrite the whole model of
charal gaming so we can cut the
Charities off at the knees and send the
money to Lottery to fund the education
trust fund because that's what this in
fact does why would you do that so I I
don't think see this as any rewrite of
any model that for for 20 plus for 20
years we've had charitable gaming and it
was based on table table games and the
poker I you know I'm not expert in that
details but what's new is the historical
the
historical horse racing machines are new
they've only been in they've only
started to roll out just in May of 2022
is when we first saw any of those
machines and they've escalated
dramatically you said part of your what
you said is was to bring more money into
the state I think that the state can
Charities okay all right um seeing no
now I have
um this is very similar to the last one
but I have a few less pin cards I have
14 people who would like to speak um we
will Implement a two-minute uh limit but
I would also say that um I know that I I
would guess that your your thought
process for opposing this because every
single one of you opposes this that I
have a card for uh would be very similar
to your last one so um if you can U
summarize it or just come up and say
you're against it whatever um I I think
we understand the the Myriad of of
wonderful Charities that and the work
you're doing so um I I just want to
avoid a repeat of the same information
um anyways with that I'll call up uh uh
amdy
Olas hello I'm am Alis you've met me
before um I just wanted to say quickly
on the historic horse racing because it
did come out during the pandemic was a
Lifeline for a lot of the Social Service
organizations in the state and I'd just
like everyone to consider that as part
of the the whole opposition and the the
take thank you uh and I have the next
card is
Furst thank
you
uh Kevin underminer is
next Terry Highland on behalf of kemes
and Kevin and Aaron
um I want to address what uh the bill
sponsor was just just speaking
about and rep duet's question um about
HHR versus games of chance and it's it's
very relevant I just reviewed our
standard agreement from the last year um
with the Brooke casino and all game of
chance revenues were removed from the
agreement and that amount that I
referenced last
$160,000 in revenues was entirely from
historic horse
racing the brook and us a charitable
partner make these standard agreements
annually and they write them and we go
back and forth and we discuss what would
be the best strategy for everybody and
um so I want that to be on record that
it's not necessarily um one or the other
or both it can be whatever in the
standard agreement and this bill does
nothing to protect um you know games of
chance versus historic horse racing
going to these Charities so again to
repeat last year all of the revenues
from charitable gaming to our
organization came from historic horse
games thank you are there any
questions representative just for the
sake of clarity it's probably not what
should have happened there should be a
percentage split that that was well
defined in the statute so maybe you're
not reading it correctly I'm just
suggesting that you take another look I
can take at should be percentage from
table games and a percentage from HHR we
did get the entire take from HHR which I
can confidently say contributed to the
increase but potentially you're correct
that there may have been table games as
well yeah but even so massive increase
because of HHR so to the point it is a
huge part of these revenues that are
important to these
Charities any other questions thank you
P
bramy I don't
know thank you Mr chair pat bramy by the
way I'm from I'll say something new I'm
from stratum just for the record and I'm
representing
myself
um I was involved as I said earlier in
in bringing historic racing to the state
uh representative duet and I and I
insisted I insisted that in that bill we
would increase the number of Charities
to two for every night okay which we've
done and with the with the with the goal
of increasing the number of Charities
that would be benefiting from this now
from the fiscal note of the last
bill they said in
2024 there were 8115 Charities that that
received money from the games of chance
and 698 Charities that receed money from
HHR and that's because not every one of
these facilities and there's 14 or so uh
currently uh have historic racing
machines because that technology is
technology it's it requires certain
Staffing and it's a l it's it's more
complicated than it may sound so I did a
quick math on this bill if we if very
important thing have to do is if you
have your bill in front of you if you go
to line 10 and 11 of the
bill it
says what is crossed out is each license
operator each ly operating historic
racing machines must contract with two
licensed charal organizations for each
game
date that's crossed
out so I would imply that says to me
unless this bill is amended that we're
down to one charity again per night if
this bill passes the the way it is and I
did a rough calculation and I said well
let's say there's 14 facilities and and
everybody had a 10
days that would be about 36 36.5 slots
for uh for uh Charities times 14
locations that's around uh uh 511
charities
so only 511 Charities would be able to
participate at the
max and out of the currently 800 plus
815 that are there so a reduction of
about 304 Charities give or take I'm
just estimating so that's the impact of
this bill someone the the number of
Charities that can participate are going
to go away this the way the bill is
written is no longer two Charities per
each so
uh you got to understand when we first
did this bill it it took us two years to
pass this bill uh the bill uh not this
bill but to pass the uh historic racing
and it was really the Charities that
second year that came and they did
videos they did all sorts of things that
they would share with the legislators
about why why this was a thing and now
to pull this
away uh I I I'll be you know
respectfully I'm opposing this bill
obviously but it's kind of a betrayal to
these Charities you know we're changing
the game
Midstream I think that's what
representative duet was trying to say
you can't just pull the rug out from
from all these Charities and again it's
going to transfer $12.5 million will be
transferred to from the Charities to the
state and
basically as you know the net net profit
from Lottery all goes into the education
trust fund so and the prime sponsor um
is was made no quals about it that was
the motivation for this bill we want to
take money from the
Charities that sounds negative but you
want to take monies from something
established helping a lot of Charities
and moving it over to the education
trust fund which was never the intent of
what we did we we were trying to expand
the number of Charities that can be
involved so I would say if this bill
were ever to get Pass unless this thing
is the bill is
amended you're down to one charity a
night for a
facility uh which is not good so that's
all I have to say on this one thank you
I'll take questions if any qu yes
representative
Malloy thank you Mr chair thank you The
Honorable Pat abrami for taking my
question appreciate
it uh I'm doing some math here and I
just see if this makes makes sense to
you
uh that's the question see if this makes
sense to you uh you there's been an
increase in the number of Charities y
that have benefited by this uh and I
think you said there are
8815 uh that
are benefiting by by the uh gains of
chance right and
698 with historic horse racing right and
so yeah uh I mean I it's I'm the going
know from the prior Bill those two
numbers um give or take right yeah uh I
added that up to be 153
1,513 is that F 1,
1513 individual different charities no
the the maximum number of Charity is the
800 number because some some of the
facilities that they're at have both
historic racing and uh games a chance
some don't that's why one number is
smaller than the other
but again what happens is if if you're
at the brook let's say and they have
both historic racing and they have
charitable uh uh games of chance table
games um basically they those monies got
pulled together and divided
equally from both both those they gets
divided equally between the two
Charities that are sponsoring that for
those 10 days
followup follow
so H followup so how many charities in
this state are benefiting from
charitable
gaming what what 800 and what did I I'll
have to look my note 800 and
okay okay I just wanted to say one more
other thing Mr chair sure um if you go
to the FIS note on this
bill in on the last page it shows that
right now charal organizations get 8
point of of the historic racing money
they get 8.7% of the gross revenue which
is the basically they call it gross but
it's really than that after payouts okay
Lottery gets
16.25 which is goes to the state and and
The Operators get
75% uh but if way and and the commission
the I talked about last time we had the
outside Consultants verify that this was
a a fair bre split uh we that was one of
my best questions is this Fair are we
given the facilities too much uh came
back they got a clean bill of health so
again everybody as I said last time last
for the last bill in the last two or
three years since everybody is getting
more the facilities are getting more the
Charities are getting more and the um
and the lottery is getting a lot more
aka the state so this this program as it
is is helping everybody including the
state is getting a lot more Revenue
because of
this representa
elberger thank you Mr chair I want to
make sure this is only my second term so
I want to make sure I've got some dates
correct uh as I understand it uh the
original bill that involved table games
only was in 2006 and then the HHR
machines since 2022 right that's correct
that's correct all right in that time
the amount of money that's gone to
Charities has increased significantly
exponentially
exponentially followup please
followup thank you
uh at the same
time our citizens property taxes have
increased enormously because of
diminished funding for education and
other
services how would you suggest that we
tell
our citizens our
constituents we're going to let your
property taxes keep Rising because we
want to support Charities I mean this
I'm not trying to bait anybody I'm
really stuck here representative this I
mean I'll let him answer if he wants but
this is really more of a policy that
that maybe we discussed during our work
session it's it's you know if we want to
dismantle histo General basically uh
charitable gaming that's a bigger issue
we partially dismantling it now you got
to remember we had a lot less Charities
involved before historic racing machines
and we've we've met that goal of
increasing that uh number of charities
and I you know it it comes down to a a
political decision in the part of
everyone here you know do we want to
want to use this as a way of funding
education or do we want to keep on
funding the
Charities I I personally fall on the
side of you know funding the Charities I
don't like changing the the rules of the
game in the
middle again remember a lot of these
Charities were involved in supporting
bringing historic racing here and now
we're saying 3 years later well we
didn't really mean it you know we you
know we're going to take that money away
from you also is going to be less not
only less Charities involved but the
total amount that individual Charities
get will also be
reduced from the from if this bill
passes so um leave it at that I just
want to talk about one other thing U
representative Aly you you brought up
problem gambling before and we as a
commission that wasn't our charge but we
came up a lot so we had extra money we
actually had 125,000 funded to bring in
a consultant we didn't spend all of that
so we brought in a second consultant on
problem gaming and there's a whole
interesting report that they came with
all the possible solutions to problem
gaming and and
prevention uh that I I I think it' be
worthy of the Comm of the ways and means
take a Peak at uh as well it's a whole
separate report it's an appendix that
report and the original report from the
uh from the consultants in there as well
yeah we'll get a copy of that report uh
I think that's um uh there's a lot of
valuable information in there and we
don't want to reinvent the wheel so yeah
thanks for mentioning that okay uh one
last question representative om yeah
thanks just a quick quick clarifying
question you said that we would be
defunding the terrible uh organizations
through this bill I'm a little confused
wouldn't that wouldn't that be just
putting the same amount of money into a
different bucket to disperse
no well what it's going to defund the
Charities takes the charity out of them
well the
Charities could ask for the money out of
Finance couldn't
they well there's already a mechanism
state law already has a mechanism and so
we would have to that that would bring
in a whole new situation that I don't
need to answer that yeah okay thank you
representative
Reen good afternoon uh chair and uh
members of the committee thank you for
hearing from me uh my name is Kathleen
re Reen I'm the CEO of the New Hampshire
Center for nonprofits we are a Statewide
nonprofit Association that uh
strengthens and gives voice to New
Hampshire's nonprofits through
Leadership Learning opportunities and
collaboration we have more than 800
members uh currently and I'm not going
to repeat a lot of what has been said
earlier today about how incredibly
important this Revenue stream is for
nonprofits I will uh reiterate a couple
of points and that is here in New
Hampshire we rely on nonprofits for many
services that in other states are
performed by government so the fact that
the legislature decided as has been
noted to make charitable gaming was a
very important policy decision and we
would urge you to stay the course with
that um I will just leave it at that and
entertain any questions thank
Jr okay thank
Harrington hi thank you for another
opportunity to reinforce our um goals
here um in in hearing what many people
said um I'm I guess very Maybe
simplistically for our organization we
look at this as a very straightforward
way to be um quick to to be able to
react as opposed to going through
another level of you know um I don't
want to say bureaucracy but when you're
applying for Grants and when you're
doing other means to find funding it
makes it um really um difficult
especially when many of these
organizations are run by volunteers who
have other full-time jobs um being being
able to access these funds in a very
straightforward way is super helpful um
I guess I'm going to look at it as sort
of a farm totable um concept as opposed
but you flip it around it's table to
farm um so um my point is um this is
just uh something that is very helpful
to be able to you know get it get a kid
a winter jacket at school within a
couple of days as opposed to trying to
run around in source the money we're
this allows us to act very quickly and
have funds on
happened
okay uh Amy Harrington did I oh she just
spoke
didn't that's why I got confused okay
Erica
Kaa good afternoon uh my name is Erica
Kaa I am the Executive Vice President
for New Hampshire soccer association um
I already was up here before I am up
here again on in opposition of House
Bill 588 I do want to share what
charitable um gaming provides for our
members and one of those things is
ampute soccer what that is it gives a
community of people the ability to play
a game that they love we had a young man
loved soccer was a player he lost his
leg he was devastated obviously from the
trauma of losing your leg but from the
trauma of losing something that's a part
of you and that's the game of soccer for
a lot of these people he came to one of
our ampute training events and he
immediately found his Joy again and
that's something that these gaming
charitable gamings allows nonprofits to
do and I urge you not to pass it thank
you questions thank
Lily
Wellington hello again my name is Lily
Wellington I live and work in conquered
and I won't bring up any of the other um
wonderful points that um my fellow
nonprofit employees have brought up but
I did want to um talk a little bit about
how we I think are both trying to do the
same thing we all have obligations when
it comes to funding right so I have an
obligation um to make sure that I'm
providing Services uh to the community
to our most vulnerable members as well
as to my staff you have an obligation to
meet the various needs of your
constituents and the state um and one of
the points that I wanted to bring up was
that
14% of the state's Workforce is employed
by a nonprofit
and my concern here is that if you start
to pick one thread of a very very
tenuous funding situation you could pull
and unravel an entire sweater without
you Amy holling grath
hello thank you for letting me speak
again again my I'm Amy hollingworth and
I'm the executive director of nhmi in
the safe Sports Network program um again
um basically um trying not to repeat
things that you've heard before but
trying to continue to relay the impact
that um the charitable gaming and the
HHS um art does for us um um so
charitable gaming has been a life a
vital lifeblood as you know for a lot of
nonprofits across us so just want to
again um remind at a time when you know
it uh the economy is already strain
leading to unfortunate downfall of many
nonprofits already um putting the
interest of the Lottery Commission above
the welfare of of these nonprofits um is
is something that we are against so
again respectfully asking you to um
reject the HB
Ali can you hear me now good afternoon
my name is Michelle Ali again I am the
CEO of Webster house Children's Home
which has been around for 141 years I'm
so very proud to be a part of that
mission and I am testifying in
opposition of HB
588 again I just want to reiterate that
um based on our contract with the state
of New Hampshire we receive a daily rate
um from the state which covers only half
of our expenses 50% of our expenses it
is my sole job and responsibility to to
meet that Gap to close that Gap and I'm
so eternally grateful for the funding
that we have received from charitable
gaming it will negatively impact our
operation if we do not have that funding
I strongly urge you to reject HB 588
tant thank you Mr chairman and you did
an even better job with the
pronunciation that time
around
bour I uh the in marketing they say you
need to hear a message seven time for it
to sink in so hopefully I've said
bonjour a few times and you'll say it to
me the next time you see me on the
street uh but uh with regard to this uh
legislation certainly um uh I'm I'm with
the the Franco American Center we're
against it um back in uh earlier this
afternoon I was looking through my
MySpace profile and I
realized that that's what I had back in
2006 and um you know now I've actually
evolved to Facebook maybe never to go to
Instagram or Tik Tok for sure but um but
I think that this charitable gaming has
certainly evolved over time in the uh
inclusion of historical horse racing has
helped to make more money available to
more nonprofits to do more good in our
communities and um so I hope that you'll
uh certainly uh vote against this
legislation and uh the uh moving of uh
historic racing into uh the education
appleberg so good afternoon hello again
I'm starting to enjoy going after my
friend John the crazy Frenchman um I'll
send you an email from my AOL account
shortly
I um am the President of the United Way
of Greater NASA of course we are here
encouraging you to vote HB 588 in
expedient legislate we look at this as
I'd like to say
we what what we really see going on here
is this is in fact a tax on the
nonprofit sector nothing nothing short
of that it's a 122.5 million tax on the
nonprofit sector
now it's hard for me I mean how would
the United Way guys say don't fund
education of course we think it's
important to fund education we just
don't think it should be done on the
back of the sector which is also trying
to support
education when historic horse racing
went
into into um place and I spent several
years thank you to representative abami
taking us down memory lane talking to
this committee about that there was an
extreme push there was a push to double
the number of Charities that there are
in the state and there's also been a
push which wasn't mentioned to um
strongly encourage the gaming operators
to reduce the number of days they give
to seven even though 10 is what is um
Allowed by Statute
so when representative fellows thinks
that there will be this increasing trend
of Revenue what that doesn't take into
account is if you pull away historic
horse racing you're also still having in
place double the number of Charities
with less days on the on their on their
plate this will in fact absolutely take
away money from from the charities in
the state um I really don't have any
other points to make than that but I do
appreciate you listening and uh would
encourage you to vote in expedient on
that is all the pin cards I have um is
there anyone else that would like to
speak
if okay and I would ask you just fill
out a pin card later um and pass it upy
to do thank you so
much hi everyone my name is Don Belmore
I'm accompanying Amy hollingworth on
behalf of nhmi and the safe Sports
network uh this has been an invigorating
day watching democracy at work and I
know I'm in a I'm in a tough spot cuz
I'm extending our Day by a little bit of
time but there was precedent someone
other folks have talked about both bills
together so as an observer from the back
I think um if you've ever heard the
analogy I don't have any swimmers or
divers in the room no sport folk okay so
the only thing that's similar about
swimming and Diving is the fact that
there's a pool and there's water I think
what it's been interesting to me today
as I listen to these bills and I listen
to the discussion and the vibrant
discussion from my peers is the only
thing that is the thread between these
two bills that brought all of us us here
to talk to you today is in fact the
charitable gaming portion and all of our
nonprofits so the first bill aimed to
say that some Charities were making too
much money or unfairly more than other
Charities and so the resolution to that
for that bill that was proposed was
instead to just Cap all of us at the
same dollar
amount without scaffolding people that
were making less or taking those funds
and letting them go to other people
people who as you say are unable to
break into charitable gaming themselves
with this bill the same thing I'm
hearing is that again a subset of folks
that are getting an opportunity to make
some of this income are going to just be
completely cut out because theirs
happens to be given to them through
historic horse racing and instead it
won't be given to any other Charities
who are doing this ground Stakes effort
work for the citizens of New Hampshire
and they're again giving it
to I'm so sorry for my ignorance the the
Lottery
Commission I did try to research things
before coming today I don't know how
quickly government works but my personal
preparation for today was very
short and I know I'm showing my
ignorance I appreciate you I just want
to say that I had a lot of trouble
figuring out the fund that the Lottery
Commission all of its work like what
does it function to do I saw things like
fees and I I don't know I it really
looked as though that fund might do a
lot of different things and so I can't
confidently say that I knew it was
directly going to go to education like
some of my other people have said I
appreciate the opportunity I would love
to engage in more dialogue I think this
is very important work and I appreciate
everyone's time here
today thank you very
oh
know so thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Comm as well so a quick point I
wanted to make and I do apologize if
this has already been discussed I'm
sorry what was your name I'm sorry uh
do thank you okay sorry about that uh so
very quickly something I hadn't
discussed before so having this funds if
the bill passes go to a large amount of
money go to the Lottery Commission what
is the cost that the Lottery Commission
is going to incur to handle that money
and so with charitable contributions
with nonprofits money is very important
currently the allocation of that money I
think I heard $15 million a year roughly
that's being handled by by the gaming
companies themselves as well as
nonprofits trying to get the money to go
to them so if the money goes to the
Lottery Commission does the Lottery
Commission have in its budget additional
funds to manage this money thank you
thank
you is there anyone else who would like
to
testify okay seeing none I'm going to
oh
okay the time being 1:48 I'm going to
open the public hearing on HB
591 and uh Prime sponsor is not here so
I'll uh ask um representative Tierney to
introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record my name is uh Jim Tierney I'm the
representative for Coos one which is
Dalton Lancaster North umberland and
Stratford and I am actually pinch
hitting here for Brian Cole uh I'm not
one and this one basically is to expand
the hours for Keno gaming on
weekends and if you look at the the bill
there we go uh it keeps everything on
the weekdays the same but on the
weekends it'll expand them to uh 8:00
a.m. to 1:00 a.m. from the current 11:00
a.m. to 1:00 a.m. and that is all this
bill does and if you look at the fiscal
note estimates for 2025 are zero Revenue
but for 26 27 and 28 on it's
11,455 and 26 and then
22299 uh as far as they're showing so
it's an increase of Revenue it's just
giving gu folks an extra three hours to
do you know if there's um was there
already times on Saturday and
know yeah it was just 11 uh 1 11:00 a.m.
to 1: a.m. on Saturdays and Sundays and
they want to change them now to 8: a.m.
to 1:
a.m.
591 and now we're only 20 minutes behind
schedule M Mr chairman yes do I remember
correctly that we voted to expand the
hours last term and this is a further
extension I don't remember um does
anyone was wasn't it
was thank you that's right yeah thank
we're going to start our exec session uh
excuse me Mr chairman I didn't know if
there he we appreciate him being here
case
e
all right looks like everyone's back
here and and um I'm pleased to report
that we're not too far behind schedule
we did a good job catching
up
so I'm going to open the executive
session on HB 502 and recognize
representative U ulery for a uh motion I
move itl Mr chair do I have a second
duet any
discussion yeah represent
chairman uh this itl of complete
corporate reporting that is being uh
proposed for House Bill 502 is saying
that we here in the
state have one party that supports this
two-tier rule of law in regards to tax
liability one for New Hampshire domestic
companies versus foreign multinational
compan companies the New Hampshire
Supreme Court said in 1986 in a written
opinion The Waters Edge method was
adopted for the benefit of foreign
businesses the nature of Waters Edge
formula requires that foreign
subsidiaries be treated differently than
New Hampshire domestic
subsidiaries the difference is that the
New Hampshire domestic subsidiaries
income is subject to taxation while
foreign multinational subsidiaries
income is not in New Hampshire the New
Hampshire Supreme Court The Waters Edge
method eliminates overseas business
organizations from subjection to the New
Hampshire business profits tax this is
not a new tax this is not a new tax rate
the reported tax liability Revenue when
included in the BPT paid to the state of
New Hampshire Dr like our New Hampshire
domestic companies presently do would
put additional Revenue in the education
trust fund
providing property tax relief by
increasing public education funding this
bill says in conclusion just pay the
full tax liability like our domestic New
Hampshire Community businesses are doing
equal under the law not two
tears thank you Mr
chairman thank you any other discussion
yes represent
Opel I think fundamentally the issue is
one of
trust democracy and the rule of law
function on the fundamental principle
that we
trust that we'll all be treated the same
and yet those people who run the
Hampshire businesses are not treated the
same as foreign
multinationals as representative
shamberg said we have a the Hampshire
Supreme Court decision that explicitly
makes that point
um one other quick thing uh there have
been some representations about the
commission report I would hope
again that before you vote on the
floor that you would take the
opportunity to read both the majority
and the minority
reports um I think it's important to
read
both one of the things you will notice
in the majority report is all although
it was represented as this 7 to1
vote in fact it was
not uh the representative from Bia very
explicitly said they weren't taking a
position the representative from the CPA
Society said very explicitly they were
not taking a
position the representative from the
Department of Revenue Administration
said very explicitly they were not
taking a
position the actual only votes to take a
position
were the four legislative members
including representative shamberg who
was the one vote against the majority
report um and there were a number of
things I think in the majority report
that The Minority Report
refuted um so I would urge you to read
both um but
again
um there was uh someone that I worked
with at the
Pentagon a Navy Admiral who
said once that you can surge people and
you can surge equipment but you can't
surge
trust and this is fundamentally a
question of trust whether the people of
New Hampshire can trust that the tax
system is the same for everyone thank
you Mr
chairman representative JY thank you Mr
chair yes please if you have the time
and uh are uh unable to go to sleep you
can read both of the uh reports um
they're relatively uh complete and in
detail uh of the commission that
representative spillsbury chaired I was
on that I was one of the seven in favor
and yes agencies did not vote because
agencies should not vote on legislative
uh commission reports and the CPA
Association did not vote although their
testimony was that uh trying to uh
enforce this was going to be rather
complex as was indicated by the
department of ourd when they spoke here
uh the fact of the matter is revenues
have increased under their current tax
system and they would likely have
decreased under the 40y old proposal
that is being made by uh the uh other
side thank you Mr chair
anybody
else yes elberger thank you Mr chairman
my re my recall which I admit sometimes
is getting fuzzy lately of
Representative
spilsbury's testimony here boil down to
opposition because getting something
like this implemented was going to be
too difficult that was the main
opposition and I respect difficulty we
all know that we live with difficulties
and we're dealing with a difficult
budget but to present the only
opposition as this would be too hard to
implement to me does not seem a
sufficient condition to vote against it
thank
you okay seeing no more discussion I'll
ask the clerk to call the role thank you
Mr chairman we are voting on House Bill
502 FN a bill rela relative to complete
corporate reporting for unitary
businesses under the business profits
tax and revenues from the state
education property tax the motion on the
floor is inexpedient to
legislate representative
alry on House Bill
502 I vote
I representative du set
yes clerk votes
yes representative sui yes
representative ORS yes representative
Stevens Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative berer Brier yes
representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
Aly no representative Southworth no
representative Malloy
no representative sham
no representative Bolton no
Representative elberger no
representative Jeffrey Smith no
representative Opel
no representative Spar no chairman
janigan
no no it's it's phonetic janigian J the
uh it's going to be a long two years
missing yeah everyone's here it should
be
119 um represent op op will do the
Minority
Report um Tom they both
Tom
lot okay I'll close the executive
502 next up I'm going to open the exec
session on hb3
18 and recognize um representative sodi
for a motion
now the motion is uh
duet and would you like to speak to your
motion sure um this bill basically
doesn't increase any funding it just
looks to shift money or money's around
from one pocket of the government to the
other pocket problem is it's going to a
pocket that has a hole in it
the education system um the inflation
rate is
uh it doesn't so
far the school funding has outpaced
inflation
exponentially
um that issue is going to be addressed
hopefully by the new committee on uh Pol
funding policy so I don't see any need
for this bill okay anybody else
chairman I stand in opposition to the
itl
motion I'm standing for the taxpayers of
wilmet and Sutton that I represent and
for the rest of
the property taxpayers of New Hampshire
I'm standing for property tax
relief this is one out of the- boox
approach of present tax revenue it does
not increase taxes it just changes the
percentage established under title
577 e colon
14 the intent is to increase the amount
of the business Enterprise tax that
would be deposited into the education
trust fund it would be a
43.9%
increase of $68 million estimated and it
would provide an option for the
legislature to address adequate funding
issues this bill does not increase any
tax
rates thank you Mr
chairman represent
elme thank you this bill does not
increase any tax rates but it does move
badly needed money from the general fund
to the education trust
fund and and at that point the finance
committee will be able to decide what to
do with it in the education trust
against okay anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the
role thank you Mr chairman we're voting
on House Bill 318 FN relative to the
percentage of revenue from the business
Enterprise tax deposited in the
education trust fund the motion is
itl representative Olie hi
representative ducet yes clerk votes yes
representative Sai yes representative
ores yes Representative Steven Smith yes
representative Tierney yes
representative Byer R ryer
representative Ford thank you sir stand
corrected
rort
yes representative Mary Murphy yes
representative
Aly representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton yes
Representative elberger no
representative Jeffrey Smith no
representative
Opel no representative Spar yes chairman
janigian
said we have to do another one uh by a
account of 16
to4
it the vote 16 for for itl is there
going to be a Minority Report
chairman okay with that I'll close the
318 reg
calendar yes regular
calendar next week we
stay okay now I will open the executive
session on HB 255 and
recognize representative sodi and the
motion again is
second any discussion on that motion uh
would you like to speak to your motion
well the same reasons as before doesn't
address Runway
costs okay Mr chairman uh representative
sham something to say I do have a
slightly different
approach
um oops
Yeah
wrong the intent of this bill uh was to
increase the amount of business profits
tax that would go into the education
trust fund it would be
150 $8
million
um I am as I
campaigned uh said we have to think out
of the box to resolve this uh issue of
uh public education funding adequate
funding and addressing the
swep I uh was hoping that this committee
would say Okay
4159 let's go 50/50
but we're not getting there so I'm still
standing for property tax relief I am
also standing for the taxpayers of
Wilman and Sutton that I campaigned on
this there would be property tax relief
and if I'm the only uh Democrat that
will stand up for that that's what I'm
going to do so I once again uh uh do not
favor the approach being taken by the
seeing no other desire to speak I'll ask
the clerk to call the
you get caught up here this is
yes thank you we are voting on House
Bill 25- FN increasing the percentage of
Revenue deposited into the education
trust fund from the business profits
tax motion on the floor is
itl representative
alry
I representative duet yes clerk votes
yes representative Sai yes
representative ores yes Representative
Steven Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative
Aly representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton yes
Representative elberger no
representative Jeffrey Smith no
representative Appel
no representative Spar yes chairman Jan
janigan
yes
okay and with that we'll I'll close the
up Mr chairman when would you like those
minority reports yesterday afteron
yesterday well I've got two here already
written out no do you tomor have them
written out email
uh tomorrow would be good okay we have a
chance to get them into the calendar uh
you have yours done
yeah you oh no I'm sorry yeah you're
yeah you've got two you've got two so if
everyone can get it done by
um you
have
have NO2
38 okay yeah so if everyone can get
their if you can get your minority uh
reports Into Me by noon time tomorrow
would be appreciated so we can try to
get it onto the calendar thank you I'm
sorry Mr chair should we email them
directly to you or to Jennifer or how uh
email them to me you can yeah you can
okay okay good with that I'll open the
exact session on HP
135 and recognize representative
ulery uh move
you want to Second it motion of itl on
HB
135 I'm not sure what he said I said
it I was confused
also sorry so the mo the motion is yeah
seconds um and would you like to speak
to your
uh uh for the record yes uh this has
come up several times um previously when
we were discussing the Wayfair uh uh
situation and it was before our
committee uh representative Aly was
chair uh and we discussed this rather
thoroughly I was in favor of this type
of activity however uh I will quote from
a a comment of the uh Attorney General
New Hampshire attorney general at the
time no argument was presented in
Wayfair that South Dakota's collections
e efforts were prohibited by Protections
in another State's Constitution that was
just not an issue uh the uh do Hampshire
attorney general went on to say that all
this all that the Wayfair decision did
was shift the point of sale from where
the money was collected to where the
representative elme could just add a bit
to that uh representative major and I
worked this issue delaying it for many
years uh but it went to the US Supreme
Court it had about 45 of the states
behind it and it had one state us
against it and the US Supreme Court
decided the issue and
and uh put and suggested guidelines
guard guard rails for it uh in their
report both the majority and The
Minority Report suggested guard rails uh
and what the bill that we crafted
together all of us uh including Jess
Edwards in the end yeah uh uh s did was
to say if you go if you violate these
implicit guard rails we're take we'll
we'll figure out how to take you to the
Supreme Court
again
get okay representative y yeah and to
follow up on that the the bill that came
out of ways and means at that time was
adopted by the house uh and we heard uh
testimony on this bill that there was no
one that really has uh uh utilized that
bill
uh the key element here is Nexus of
business um operations and uh if you're
large enough to sell a couple billion
dollars worth of well $100,000 worth of
goods in another place well you're
selling to that other place so you're
subject to their laws it already applies
in a lot of stuff that I buy over the
Internet uh with Amazon if their if
their home state has the sale tax in New
Hampshire doesn't have a sales tax it's
delivered to my driveway and I don't pay
a sales
tax so it already is you know it
works thank you anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role thank you Mr chairman we
are voting on House Bill 135 relative to
the collection of sales taxes of foreign
jurisdictions by New Hampshire
businesses motion on the floor is
itl representative
alry
I representative ducet yes clerk votes
yes representative sodi yes
representative ores yes Representative
Steven Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative Aly yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative Jeffrey Smith yes
representative uple I representative
Spar yes chairman denigan yes 20
Z the vote being 20 to zero uh if
there's no objection we'll put this on
consent seeing none it goes it will go
on
consent okay now um I'll close the
executive session on HB
135 that um that concludes uh today's
executive session I will say I'll modify
what I said slightly earlier if you can
get me the majority and minority reports
tonight sometime that would actually be
better because getting them to me
tomorrow at noon time means that um we
have a we have a meeting and I'll have
to review them during that time
if if you can't get it till noon time
tomorrow that's fine but I would ask if
you can get it to me tonight uh that
everyone okay
now what are we doing
tonight he there a newbie what's
the it's just a couple
sent yeah it can be
um it can be a couple sentences can be
longer whatever you think is necessary
to
explain two or three sentences it
doesn't have to be long yeah I mean if
it's going to be because it's all
printed in the calendar I don't want to
go on no one's going to read it that too
they may not read it anyway but um you
can probably find an example like we
good
e